ich eröffne die aussprache und als
erstes erhält das wort carsten körper
für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren es ist
vollbracht
elf wochen voller intensiver
haushaltsberatungen liegen hinter uns
neulich habe ich meine rede in der
ersten lesung mit einem deutlichen und
klanglos an unserer außenministerin
begonnen und heute stelle ich fest sie
liebe frau ministerin und ihr aus haben
das niveau gehalten
das auswärtige amt und das konnte ich in
den letzten wochen intensiv erleben das
ist ganz offensichtlich vom geist und
von der kultur auch ein haus das ist als
eine ehrenvolle aufgabe begreift
vertretern der legislative
auskunft und informationen zu geben
gerade auch denen der opposition da
können sich viele andere häuser gerne
eine scheibe abschneiden
der etat des auswärtigen amtes liegt in
diesem jahr inklusive ergänzungs
haushalt bei rund 7,5 milliarden euro
sechseinhalb milliarden im
regierungsentwurf und zirka eine
milliarde dann in den parlamentarischen
beratung und ob das ist ein rekord aber
das ist ein rekord über den sich keiner
von uns wirklich freuen kann denn wir
alle kennen den grund für diesen rekord
etat er kann uns nicht glücklich machen
ganz im gegenteil aktuell erleben wir
mit dem russischen angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine die schlimmste aggression in
europa seit 1945 der russische angriff
auf die ukraine hat es leider
erforderlich gemacht diesen etat wie
viele andere das auch massiv zu erhöhen
der krieg zeigt seine dramatischen
folgen beinahe überall auf der welt
deswegen war es gut richtig und leider
auch notwendig dass allein die mittel
für humanitäre hilfe im auswärtigen amt
um 700 millionen euro erhöht worden
der bedarf für humanitäre hilfe weltweit
steigt dramatisch werden noch 2009 10
weniger als 20 milliarden weltweit der
bedarf war so liegt er in diesem jahr
leider schon bei über 43 milliarden als
bundesrepublik deutschland tun wir was
wir tun können immerhin sind wir nach
den usa der zweitgrößte geber weltweit
es gebe im detail sicher noch vieles
kritisieren so zu kritisieren als union
zum beispiel sind uns die einschnitte
gerade im bereich der auswärtigen kultur
und bildungspolitik zu groß wir glauben
wir dass viel engagement potenzial und
know how zu grabe getragen wird mit
diesem haushalt aber ich möchte mich
hier in dieser rede auf einen besonderen
geradezu skandalösen missstand
beschränken und damit meine ich die
verschleierungstaktik die das
finanzministerium beim ergänzungs
haushalt gefahren ist das auswärtige amt
beispielsweise erhält aus dem ergänzungs
haushalt
450 millionen euro das ist beinahe eine
halbe milliarde dafür bekommt man
übrigens mehr als 12.000 funkel
niegelnagelneue vollelektrische vw id3
die übrigens in meiner heimat zwickau
gebaut werden
auch der ergänzungs haushalt würde er
neulich beschlossen nicht beschlossen
wurde aber die aufteilung wird für das
bmf die mittel anzahl gibt uns ist zwar
die antrags liste bekannt aber diese
liste sie ist eben nicht verbindlich was
hat das mit haushaltsklarheit und
haushaltswahrheit zu tun aber es kommt
noch schlimmer der ergänzungs haushalt
erhält eine globale mehrausgaben in höhe
von 13,7 milliarden euro dafür bekommt
man übrigens schon 370.000 id3 diese
mittel kann das bmf dann nach gutdünken
auf die einzelnen ressorts verteilen das
ist nichts weniger als die mutwillige
entmachtung des haushalts gesetzgebers
durch die exekutive die ampel regierung
legt ihr die axt an das budgetrecht des
parlaments liebe haushälter kolleginnen
und kollegen der ampel dass sie dieses
spiel von bundeskanzler scholz und
finanzminister lindner mitgespielt haben
das finde ich wirklich schade
für die dann im herbst anstehenden
haushaltsberatungen wünsche ich ihnen
dringend mehr parlamentarisches
selbstbewusstsein
da sie das brauchen das zeigt auch noch
ein weiteres beispiel gern hätte die
union einen antrag der koalition
zugestimmt im auswärtigen amt eine
länder datenbank aufzubauen sozusagen
eine maßnahmen übersicht auf knopfdruck
die sollte es geben ein neuer aufschlag
war geplant nachdem ein anderes ressort
seit zwei jahren an dieser stelle nicht
liefern aber dieser antrag kam nicht ich
weiß dass sie als berichterstatter
willens waren wir haben viel im vorfeld
darüber gesprochen das projekt wurde
aber trotzdem verhindert offenbar andere
die es selber nicht besser können sie
haben es durchgehen lassen die kollegen
von der ampel wider besseren wissens und
dass das ist für mich das eigentlich
traurig das ist der eigentliche skandal
aber
wie heißt es so schön nach dem spiel ist
vor dem spiel ich möchte mich für die
engagierten verhandlungen bei meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen mit
berichterstattung herzlich bedanken und
ebenso möchte ich mich bedanken bei
allen beteiligten im auswärtigen amt
herzlichen dank
carsten körper war das für die
unionsfraktion hat hier die debatte um
den einzelplan 5 des auswärtigen amts
eröffnet und auf ihn folgten jamila
schäfer sie sitzt einerseits im
ausschuss im auswärtigen ausschuss als
auch im haushaltsausschuss und
kollegen die deutsche außenpolitik war
leider lange geprägt von einem
gefährlichen irrglauben dass
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
automatisch frieden und menschenrechte
stärkt egal ob wir nach butter oder
nacht lang gucken wir werden laufend
eines besseren belehrt eine von
wirtschaftlichen interessen geprägte
außenpolitik die sich sonst in
zurückhaltung übt übernimmt nicht nur zu
wenig verantwortung
sie kann sogar zu gefährlichen
abhängigkeiten von autoritären
machthaber führen und der werte und
regelbasierten ordnungs schaden
der haushalt des auswärtigen amtes den
wir hier heute beschließen worten wollen
setzt deswegen auf eine ganz andere
außenpolitik
er rückt den fokus auf eine aktive
prävention von krisen auf eine werte
geleitete sicherheitspolitik und auf
eine klima außenpolitik die länder des
globalen südens als gleichberechtigte
partner versteht er unterstreicht
er unterstreicht den anspruch unsere
ministerin an der lena bernburg dass
menschenwürde und freiheit die werte auf
denen unser völkerrecht einst gebaut
wurde unsere außenpolitik leiten die
nachrichten aus china zeigen uns genauso
wie die traurige geschichte rund um most
in zwei wirtschaftsinteressen gehörenden
hinter universelle werte angestellt zum
schutz von menschenrechten und zum
schutz unserer sicherheit
eine aktive aussenpolitik braucht eine
angemessene finanzielle ausstattung und
wenn wir diesen haushalt heute
beschließen der kollege hat körper hatte
schon angesprochen wird der etat für das
auswärtige amt so groß sein wie nie
zuvor
7,56 milliarden inklusive des ergänzung
des haushaltes und das ist angesichts
eines neuen imperialistischen krieges in
europa angriffe auf demokratien weltweit
und der globalen klimakrise genau
richtig
wir vergrößern
unser engagement in der humanität und
hilfe auf ein rekordniveau von 2,7
milliarden euro wir starten die zivile
krisenprävention mit einem höchstwert
von rund 600 millionen euro aus mit
auslauf höchsten zb auch in der kultur
außenpolitik bei den goethe instituten
und bei den politischen stiftungen und
ganz besonders hat mich gefreut die
anschubfinanzierung für das nothilfe
referat von verfolgten wissenschaftler
innen aus russland und aus belarus damit
damit bieten wir wichtigen stimmen aus
eines pluralistischen osteuropas eine
perspektive das ist menschlich
wahnsinnig wichtig aber es ist auch
sicherheitspolitisch richtig denn jede
investition in eine starke
zivilgesellschaft in autoritären ländern
ist auch eine investition in unsere
sicherheit
unsere außenpolitik gut auf
multilateralismus der völkerrechtlichen
ordnung und einer engen partnerschaft
mit den ländern dieser welt die sich für
stabilität und demokratie einsetzen dazu
gehört es natürlich auch die tätigkeiten
der vereinten nationen zu stärken
und noch eine bemerkung zum thema
zusammenarbeit mit afrika an unseren
umgang mit den afrikanischen staaten und
wird sich unser außenpolitisches handeln
vielleicht noch mit am stärksten messen
lassen hier können und hier müssen wir
zeigen dass wir als europäische union
der partner für wirtschaftliche
humanitäre und politische allianzen ist
mit diesem haushalt liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen schaffen wir das fundament
für eine werte geleitete aussenpolitik
vielen dank dafür an meine mit
berichterstatterin an unsere auf
ministerin annalena baerbock und an die
verfolgung zusammenarbeit auch nochmal
mit dem auswärtigen amt vielen
herzlichen dank
janina schäfer hat sich auch hier bei
ihren kolleginnen und kollegen gedankt
auch sie ist eine berichterstatterin für
diesen einzelplan und auch der nächste
redner ist für seine fraktion
berichterstatter michael espendiller
mitglied des haushaltsausschusses und
der arche fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
bei youtube am giebel dieses gebäudes in
dem wir uns gerade befinden steht
geschrieben dem deutschen volke danach
müsste es eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein dass sich
auch die deutsche außenpolitik an diesem
leitsatz ausrichtet doch leider sehen
wir in vielen fällen das gegenteil im
deutschen interesse wäre es sparsam mit
den deutschen steuergeldern umzugehen
und sich genau zu überlegen wie man
dieses geld einsetzt es wären deutschen
interessen schulden abzubauen und auf
solide finanzen hinzuwirken
und doch haben wir in den schlussgeraden
bei den haushaltsberatungen erlebt wie
eine optimistische steuerschätzung für
das jahr 2022 dazu geführt hat dass der
etat des auswärtigen amtes über die
sieben milliarden euro grenze gehoben
wurden die mehrausgaben von rund einer
halben milliarde euro fließen fast
ausschließlich in richtung ukraine
wohlgemerkt zusätzlich zu dem was
ohnehin schon vorgesehen war was auch
noch aus anderen etats kommt damit
fließt das geld in ein land mit dessen
kriegsgebeutelten volk sich wohl jeder
solidarisiert der ein herz in der brust
hat wo man sich aber auch gleichzeitig
die frage stellen muss was mit diesem
geld eigentlich passiert und ob es
tatsächlich da ankommt wo es gebraucht
wird und nicht in irgendwelche
undurchsichtigen kanälen versickert das
residence gegen den pandora papers
auftaucht und man ihnen noch letzten
herbst der korruption bezichtigt will ja
momentan keiner hören ist für mich als
haushälter tatsächlich aber auch schon
nebensächlich denn der entscheidende
punkt bei der ausgabenpolitik im
auswärtigen amt ist für mich die
mangelnde evaluation es gibt im grunde
keinerlei bilanz keinerlei auswertung
und keinerlei erfolgskontrolle darüber
was der einsatz er arbeitet deutschen
steuergeldes im ausland eigentlich
konkret bringt tatsächlich
tatsächlich werte kollegen ist man im
auswärtigen amt bis heute nicht in der
lage auf nachfrage sagen zu können was
genau in welchem land mit welchem
beitrag zu welchem zweck gefördert wird
niemand hat einen gesamtüberblick über
die den undurchdringbar 'ran wildwuchs
an projekten die weltweit mit deutschem
steuergeld finanziert werden aber im
ausschuss sind sich alle anderen
fraktionen einig dass man auf jeden fall
mehr geld braucht das ist absolut
verrückt
wenn frau ministerin bernburg hat in den
braten zugesichert dass man bis zum
herbst ein system entwickelt haben will
mit dem man auf knopfdruck daten zu den
weltweiten projekten des auswärtigen
amtes abrufen kann das finden das findet
nicht nur zustimmung sondern wir fordern
dass auch ein denn nur wenn wir endlich
einmal ein gesamtüberblick bekommen
können wir auch mit einer echten
evaluation beginnen und uns ausgiebig
der frage widmen wo wir geld sparen
können bis dahin möchte ich der
regierung aber auch noch ein paar kurze
anmerkung dazu mitgeben was den
interessen dieses landes dient und was
nicht ein gas embargo gegen russland ist
nicht im deutschen interesse
denn das bedroht in großer zahl
arbeitsplätze und führt zu neuen
haushalterischen belastung im bereich
arbeit soziales und wirtschaft es führt
zu unkalkulierbaren risiken
zu unkalkulierbaren risiken bei unserer
energiesicherheit man kann die frage
womit denn im nächsten winter in
deutschland geheizt werden soll nicht
einfach unbeantwortet lassen und man
kann auch nicht über die jahrzehnte
geschaffene abhängigkeit deutschlands
von energieimporten die kann man nicht
ignorieren und zu tun als gäbe es sie
nicht bei allem verständnis für die
aktuelle situation
die solidarität mit der ukraine darf
nicht so weit gehen dass wir unseren
wirtschaftsstandort gefährden und die
menschen im nächsten jahr bei uns im
winter frieren und zu guter letzt auch
waffenlieferung an die ukraine sind
nicht im deutschen interesse was auch
eine wachsende mehrheit in der
bevölkerung so sieht
vor diesem hintergrund ist es geradezu
ironisch dass die inschrift dem
deutschen volke draußen im haus
eingeschmolzenen kanonen gefertigt wurde
die bundesregierung sollte über die
tiefere bedeutung punkt dieser
materialauswahl vielleicht noch einmal
nachdenken und zur besinnung kommen
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
michael müller hat sich hier noch einmal
auf unser gegen sanktionen auf kosten
der wirtschaft ausgesprochen
die abstimmung geschlossen wird also
falls das noch mitglieder des hauses
gibt sollten sie sich jetzt auf den weg
machen als nächstes erhält das wort der
kollege doktor nils schmid für die so
nächster redner ist nun in nils schmid
der außenpolitische sprecher der spd
fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren zunächst einmal möchte
ich mich bei den mitgliedern des
haushaltsausschusses
bedanken für die
verbesserungen am etat des einzel plans
des auswärtigen amtes die vorgenommen
worden sind
dieser dank gilt natürlich in erster
linie auch der berichterstatterin der
spd-bundestagsfraktion liebliche parken
pro die diese woche entschuldigt ist und
dennis rohde als sprecher der sie auch
die letzte zeit vertreten hat dann geht
aber auch das will ich ausdrücklich
sagen an die gute vorbereitung im
auswärtigen amt vor allem auch an
staatssekretärin baumann die dafür
gesorgt hat dass die grundlage für
diesen guten beratungen gelegt worden
sind also ein herzliches danke an all
diejenigen die haushaltspolitisch hier
mitgewirkt haben
aus sicht von uns außenpolitikern ist
eine funktionstüchtige diplomatie ein
gut ausgestattetes auswärtiges amt
besonders wichtig und deshalb will ich
bei den allgemeinen haushaltsmitteln auf
einen hinweisen der uns besonders am
herzen liegt das ist der stetige
aufwuchs der personalreserve des
auswärtigen amtes der auch in diesem
haushalt fortgesetzt wird und der auch
in den folge haushalten das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen fortgesetzt werden
muss der zweite punkt der mir noch mal
wichtig erscheint heute anzumerken ist
die lösung die der haushaltsausschuss
gefunden hat für die veranschlagung der
ertüchtigung hilfe mit blick auf vor
allem die neuen herausforderungen die
aus der unterstützung für die ukraine
erwachsen das ist gut dass wir da für
diesen haushalt und auch für die folge
haushalt folge haushalte den weg gebahnt
haben und entsprechende mittel
veranschlagt haben also auch dafür ein
herzliches dankeschön
allgemein gesprochen steht auch der
haushalt des außenamtes im zeichen der
zeitenwende die außenpolitischen
möglichkeiten im bundeshaushalt werden
deutlich verstärkt angefangen mit der
militärischen seite des vernetzten
ansatzes durch die verankerung des
sondervermögens
denn wir sind uns ja einig dass
angesichts des russischen angriffskriegs
gegen die ukraine die militärische
abschreckung gestärkt werden muss und
die bundeswehr ausreichend modernisiert
werden muss wir es aber auch wichtig
dass gerade im sinne dieses vernetzten
ansatzes die mittel für die
entwicklungshilfe
angemessen in diesem haushalt ausfallen
und das auch die funktionsfähigkeit des
auswärtigen amtes einschließlich des ziv
der zivilen krisenprävention komponente
die auch im auswärtigen amt angesiedelt
ist dass diese ebenfalls gestärkt werden
denn eines ist klar diese zeitenwende
wird politisch nur dann halte ich
getragen werden können von uns im
parlament aber auch von der gesellschaft
in deutschland wenn wir im sinne dieses
vernetzten ansatzes krisenprävention
entwicklung und abschreckung
zusammendenken und diplomatie nie
aufgeben meine damen und herren
und schließlich gehört zu
der lehre die wir aus
erfolgreicher
außenpolitik
sozialdemokratisch geführte regierungen
der letzten 50 jahre schließen können
auch dazu dass genauso entschieden wie
wir gegen äußere bedrohungen
vorkehrungen treffen und die
landesverteidigung stützen genauso
entschieden wie wir auf dialog und
entspannung setzen wir genauso
entschlossen die inneren reformen
unseres landes die modernisierung von
wirtschaft und gesellschaft angehen
müssen dieser dreiklang gehört für eine
progressive fortschritte
fortschrittliche regierungspolitik aus
sozialdemokratischer sicht zusammen
sowie willy brandt den tornado mit
atombomben ausgestattet hat und
gleichzeitig das bafög eingeführt hat so
wird olaf scholz
f-35 kaufen mit dem neuen sondervermögen
und gleichzeitig das bafög modernisieren
und zusammen mit den amt mit den ampel
partnern werden wir das
staatsangehörigkeitsrecht
modernisieren werden wir die
digitalisierung vorantreiben werden wir
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
beschleunigen das ist politik aus einem
guss im sinne eines modernen deutschland
und eines modernen europas und diesen
weg wollen wir die nächsten jahre
gemeinsam von sitzen
und all das fügt sich dann zusammen in
einem begriff den olaf scholz in einem
buch schon vor einigen jahren geprägt
hat nämlich hoffnungs land
deutschland ist ein hoffnungslauf für
viele menschen bei uns selber unsere
bürgerinnen bürger für menschen die
fliehen müssen aus not aus gründen
politischer verfolgung wegen krieges und
dieses hoffnungs land symbolisiert sich
einen punkt vor schäfer hat
dankenswerter weise darauf hingewiesen
der auch im etat des einzelplan des
außenamtes verankert ist nämlich das
programm zur aufnahme von menschen aus
belarus russland ukraine die aus
politischen gründen aktuell das land
verlassen müssen journalisten akademiker
akademiker wir haben die große chance
dass dieser begriff des hoffnungslos
gerade für diese engagierte für
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit
engagierte menschen realität wird und
genau aus diesem grund wird die spd
diesem einzelplan großer freude
zustimmen herzlichen dank
nils schmid der außenpolitische sprecher
der spd-fraktion hat hier mehrere
vorhaben angesprochen die noch umgesetzt
werden sollen vor dem hintergrund des
russischen angriffskriegs auf die
ukraine will ja auch die bundesregierung
ein neues sicherheitskonzept für
deutschland erarbeiten unter anderem
soll die nato ostflanke gestärkt werden
aber die außenministerin annalena
baerbock möchte auch
darüber sprechen dass die nukleare
abschreckung der nato glaubhaft bleiben
soll die bündnisfähigkeit und
wehrhaftigkeit
deutschlands soll auch gestärkt werden
das alles sind argumente die man vorher
doch eher selten von grünen politikern
gehört hat
umbenannt werden in ein auf rüstungs
waffenexport und sanktions ministerium
denn all das wir hier an dieser politik
aus weil ich verstehen ist es in cdu csu
sich immer mit der
bundesverteidigungsminister lamprecht
auseinandersetzen in wirklichkeit macht
das doch die bundesaußenministerium
baerbock also da müssen sie die
auseinandersetzung wechseln was haben
denn diese aktion gegen china und
russland gebracht also das ziel war
china soll die uiguren anständig
behandeln machen sie es
russland sollte mit dem krieg aufhören
geschieht es nein vielleicht sollte man
mal wechseln von der sanktionspolitik
hin zu angeboten man könnte doch china
auch sagen wenn ihr die
menschenrechte gegenüber den uiguren
achtet bekommt ihr erstens zweitens
drittens warum immer nur in form von
sanktionen denken und nicht mal
umgekehrt herangehen und mit angeboten
wirklich weiter zu kommen die politik
blieb von glaubwürdigkeit lebt davon
dass sie in allen situationen und dann
alle staaten den gleichen maßstab anlegt
die außenpolitik dieser bundesregierung
ist davon aber weit entfernt
die werte die sie zu verteidigen und für
die sie bereit sind auch waffengewalt
einzusetzen gelten offenbar nicht für
alle staaten es ist keine frage dass
menschenrechte freiheit demokratie und
rechtsstaat verteidigt werden müssen und
dass die ukraine alles völkerrecht auf
ihrer seite hat seine territoriale
integrität gegen den aggressor russland
zu verteidigen doch eines bleibt
unabdingbar die entscheidung wie dieser
krieg geführt und vor allem wie er
beendet wird liegt zuallererst bei den
kriegsparteien und niemand hat das recht
der ukraine vorzuschreiben oder sie
anzutreiben diesen krieg bis zu einem
bitteren ende hin zu einer militärischen
entscheidung zu führen und das taten sie
bundesministerin baerbock als sie sagten
der krieg sei erst beendet wenn der
letzte russische soldat das ukrainische
staatsgebiet verlassen habe wenn die
ukraine aber auf einen kompromiss
eingehen sollte haben sie haben wir das
zu respektieren
zu der frage ob deutschland mit seiner
geschichte und waffen an die ukraine
liefern sollte unterschiedliche
positionen die gibt es aber offenbar
auch in der koalition ich bleibe dabei
deutschlands schuld und verantwortung
für den zweiten weltkrieg und das
menschheitsverbrechen des holocaust
hätte es uns ein für alle mal verbieten
müssen das deutsche unternehmen an
waffenexporten jemals wieder etwas
verdienen auch der schaden
deutschland ist aber der größte
waffenexporteur der welt wer so viel
waren exportiert exportiert auch krieg
und macht eben mitkriegen gewinnen wenn
jürgen habermas und andere gegenwärtig
zur besonnenheit aufrufen was ihr gutes
recht ist werden sie beschimpfen
sie frau bundesministerin haben in bezug
auf den krieg aus tanz gegen die ukraine
die befürchtung geäußert dass unsere
bevölkerung ist die tiere sie wörtlich
kriegsmüde wird was wäre denn die
alternative soll die deutsche
bevölkerung etwa kriegs begeistert
werden
ausgerechnet sie die oberste deutsche
diplomaten wollen in deutschland also
die akzeptanz dafür steigern dass
konflikte kriegerisch gelöst werden dazu
möchte ich kein haus zitieren der saß
die kriegsmüde das ist das dümmste von
allen worten die die zeit hat kriegsmüde
sein das heißt müde sein des mordes müde
des raubes mittel der lüge würde der
dummheit müde des hungers mit der
krankheit moodle des schmutzes würde das
chaos war man geht zu all dem frisch und
munter ich sage ihnen die mehrheit
unserer bevölkerung ist friedliebend und
deshalb immer kriegs möge sie bestrafen
die russische führung sondern auch die
russische bevölkerung den krieg nicht
beschlossen hat und große teile unserer
bevölkerung sind es leid dass sie mit
energie und lebensmittelpreisen die
milliarden konsequenzen des krieges
tragen sollen während sie bei dem
einfrieren von oligarchen vermögen weit
hinter anderen staaten hinterherhinken
und im unterschied zu italien spanien
griechenland und sogar einer
entsprechenden planung in großbritannien
keine über gewinn steuer für die kriegs
gewinn konzerne für die kriegsgewinnler
in deutschland ein leben worten sieben
solcher und reicher werden aber kein
euro dafür zusätzlich bezahlen müssen
ich weiß dass die fdp dahinter steckt
das hat mit liberalisiert nicht zu tun
gar nichts
und nun so ungleichbehandlungen das
vorgehen des türkischen präsidenten
gegen die kurbeln und kurden ist
anzuprangern man hört von ihnen dazu so
gut wie nichts und
nichts macht die unglaubwürdigkeit
deutlicher als dieses schweigen erdogan
bond gegen jene kurdischen einheiten in
syrien und im irak die am boden den
entscheidenden kampf gegen den
sogenannten islamischen staates geführt
haben und sie schauen zu und liefern
warten an die türkei obwohl das ganze
auch noch völkerrechtswidrig ist nun
verlangt er auch noch für seine
zustimmung zum nato-beitritt f 16 bomber
und dass die kurdinnen und kurden
weltweit schlechter behandelt werden ich
befürchte dass er beides erreichte denkt
er wieder zum schluss herr abgeordneter
ja dann komme ich zum schluss der
gravierendsten fehler ist dass ihnen
keine ordnung für frieden und sicherheit
für die zukunft vor schrieb wie kommen
wir denn wieder zurückkehren zur
deeskalation zu
interessenausgleich es gibt auch ein
interesse des gegenüber zu sehr viel
mehr diplomatie und zur stricken bar und
des völkerrechts durch
gregor gysi war das für die linke hat
hier außenministerin annalena baerbock
stark angegriffen ihr unter anderem
vorgeworfen die ukraine zu drängen den
krieg bis zum schluss weiter zu führen
auf ihn folgt nun michael link
europapolitischer sprecher der
fdp-fraktion und berichterstatter für
diesen etat
kollegen herr gysi als sie kürzlich
stellungnahmen kurz nach dem angriff
russlands auf die ukraine hatte ich für
einen moment gedacht dass realismus
eingekehrt sei bei ihnen zumindestens
ihrer fraktion hat sich gleich anders
geäußert aber in welchen zentralkomitee
ist wenn diese rede heute geschrieben
worden sie haben heute hier einen
rückfall ein rückfall wie sie selten
erlebt habe in einem wunschdenken in
einem wunschdenken schlimmsten kalter
kriegs den namen gemacht und ich kann
ihnen nur sagen wenn sie denken dass das
funktioniert dann nutzen sie bitte die
sehr guten kontakte nach ostern in den
kreml die viele von ihnen auch haben und
übrigens auch hier auf dieser seite der
beifall hier heute für ganz links und
von ganz rechts spricht bände und zeigen
uns erneut dass die demokraten zusammen
halten müssen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen man kann viel
kritisieren ihr müsst ihr der tat viel
kritisieren bei den sanktionen aber
nicht dass es zu wenig ist sondern ich
sage es einmal ganz deutlich weil wir
gerade kurz nach dem europäischen rat
bei nach dem sondergipfel von gestern
waren was für ein erbärmliches
schauspiel wie es gelungen ist orban
aufgrund des einstimmigkeit regel und
ich sage das deutlicher als unsere
regierungsvertreterin können und dürfen
was für ein erbärmliches schauspiel das
es immer noch möglich ist dass ein land
alle anderen nasenring durch die manege
führt das muss sich ändern denn die eu
bleibt in der tat
die eu bleibt in der tat weit hinter
ihren möglichkeiten zurück und deshalb
hat sich diese koalition
koalitionsvertrag und auch in der arbeit
vorgenommen dass wir an diesem thema
arbeiten endlich zu qualifizierten
mehrheiten in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik zu kommen damit so
etwas wie gestern sich nicht wiederholt
es war ich sage es noch einmal ein
trauerspiel und wenn man sieht wie man
sich dann auch mal produziert hat dann
kann ich nur sagen lasst uns gut für uns
vorbereiten auf den nächsten
europäischen rat lasst uns auch
überlegen wie wir den wege finden wo wir
ohne einstimmigkeit erforderlich ist
jetzt schon möglichst mit regelungen
finden kreative art dass wir uns nicht
mehr erpressen lassen von einzelnen
solchen mitgliedern die erkennbar mit
putin über bande spielen wie viktor
orban zum umgang herr kollege erlangen
sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
fdp-fraktion von handys
trompeter bis tron aus der fdp-fraktion
kollegen dass wir die zwischenfrage zu
lassen sie haben sich selbst hier gerade
zu einem demokraten erklärt und im
gleichen atemzug kritisieren sie
demokratische spielregeln in der eu das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip also wie viktor
orban ist mit 54 prozent gewählt in
seinem land das sind mehrheiten von dem
sind sie hier alle von den träumen sie
nur ja er hat so eine legitimation sein
volk zu vertreten und sie ist dass ihr
verständnis von demokratie dass sie ihn
auf linie bringen wollen
herr kollege ich danke ihnen für die
frage ich empfehle ihnen mal den bericht
der wahlbeobachter der osze zu reden und
die analyse über das ungleiche war ich
über empfehlen ich empfehle ihnen zu
lesen den letzten berichts der
europäischen grundrechteagentur und auch
der medien der osze mieten freiheits
beauftragten über die fehlende
pressefreiheit in ungarn die ungarischen
wahlen als demokratische wahl zu
bezeichnen geht über das hinaus was wir
als eine vaters wir also ich bezeichne
sie nicht als eine demokratische wahl
ganz eindeutig sie ist sie ist eine wahl
in der auch das wahlrecht durch
geschickte manipulation im vorfeld dem
jetzigen regierung inhaber ist
erleichtert hat wiedergewählt zu werden
deshalb sage ich ganz deutlich das gilt
auch wenn das gilt auch überall
demokratisch gewählt heißt noch lange
nicht demokratisch gesinnt und diese
frage der demokratischen gesinnung die
frage die wir demokratie leben die zeigt
sich nicht am tag der wahl wie in
deutschland am tag der wahl wird
demokratisch in deutschland gewählt die
ob man dem ob demokrat demokrat wird man
nicht durch wahl demokrat wird man durch
haltung und das würde ich mir von ihnen
mehr wünschen
deshalb sagen wir ganz klar wir wollen
mehr mehrheits abstimmungen in der
europäischen union weil wir sie weiter
entwickeln wollen weil wir sieht auch
darum zu haben uns bekannt in unserem
koalitionsvertrag weiter entwickeln
wollen das geht aber weit über die
wahlperiode hinaus zu einem föderalen
bundesstaat weil wir sagen dass dieses
europa nicht eine zeiterscheinung ist
jeweils bis zur nächsten wahl gilt
sondern weil wir sie dauerhaft diese
europäische und stärken wollen und da
liebe kolleginnen kollegen bitte das
wäre wirklich mein punkt ermutigen wir
die bundesregierung greifen sie wirklich
vor dem nächsten europäischen rat auch
durchaus noch einmal auf die vielen
europäerinnen und europäer auch in
anderen regierungen zurück und auch hier
auf die große mehrheit in diesem hause
die sagt wir sollten der ukraine eine
europäische perspektive aufzeigen
stichwort beitrittsperspektive das wird
das große thema werden des nächsten
europäischen rates hier ermutigen wir
sie gemeinsam mit anderen mutig
voranzugehen liebe kolleginnen kollegen
kollegin schäfer hat gesprochen kollege
schmiede zugesprochen kollege körper
übrigens danke für die erfahrung
zusammenarbeit muss man wirklich sagen
hier unter demokraten die wir gemacht
haben in der region der arbeit was wir
alles verstärkt haben im haushalt jetzt
ist die zeit weit fortgeschritten
deshalb nur wenige aspekte dieser aber
wichtig sind wir haben bis das schiff
gestärkt wir haben die humanitäre hilfe
gestärkt wir haben gerade im bereich der
menschenrechtsverteidiger vieles
gestärkt wir haben die ausstattung der
visums stellen gestärkt wir haben das
visums portal die nötigen mittel
vorgesehen weil wir hier vorankommen
wollen frau ministerin danke ich eben
auch wirklich den vielen vielen aktiven
bei ihnen im haus die genau bei diesen
strukturellen sachen eben auch
vorankommen wollen in all diesen dingen
haben wir im parlamentarischen verfahren
noch einmal deutliche signale gesetzt
das war uns sehr wichtig dass wir diese
signale setzen weil das haus ist stark
gewachsen ist es eines der wichtigsten
ministerien was wir haben manchmal ist
die struktur nicht mitgewachsen jetzt
ist sie mit gewachsen weil es eben auch
leute geben muss die das alles umsetzen
was gemacht werden muss und deshalb
einerseits mehr mit humanitäre hilfe das
haben wir gemacht aber auch für die
struktur ich glaube das war ein
wichtiges signal so dass dieses haus
auch jetzt wirklich angemessen reagieren
kann dieses ministerium und liebe
kolleginnen kollegen weil es nicht
persönlich die letzte berichterstattung
war die ich gemacht habe im einzel land
5 und weil ich sozusagen die ich jetzt
auf die arbeit eben als
transatlantischer produkte konzentrieren
will ich mich ganz besonders deshalb
wirklich ganz besonders bei den vielen
angehörigen des auswärtigen dienstes
bedanken die eine fantastische arbeit
machen weltweit die oft auch in sehr
gefährlichen stellen ist genauso wie in
der zentrale auch dass es nicht so
gefährlich aber das ist manchmal
ebenfalls auch besonders schwierig und
es ist natürlich so dass mit den anderen
häusern die immer mehr auch
international tätig sind wir auch mehr
abstimmung brauchen ja das haushalt
daher sagt bitte wir brauchen mehr
kontrolle und verbände bei der
mittelverwendung in der tat da gibt es
viele gute ideen gerade auch aus dem
auswärtigen amt das sind sehr gute
vorstellung gemacht worden wir müssen
auch vorankommen bei dem thema länder
datenbank übergebe das vertrauensvoll
sozusagen an meinen nachfolger als
berichterstatter der daher weiter dran
bleiben wird und wir werden als
parlament wir müssen dranbleiben danke
wie gesagt an die hervorragenden für die
hervorragende zusammenarbeit in diesem
bereich meine fraktion stimmt diesem
einzelplan gerne zu und ich freue mich
auf die zukünftige zusammenarbeit in
anderen funktionen dankeschön
michael link hat er sich auch noch mal
bedankt es war schon anfang des jahres
bekannt geworden dass er mit der
koordinator für die transatlantische
zusammenarbeit werden soll und sich dann
hier auch noch mal bei den anderen
berichterstattung gedanken des
haushaltsausschusses zu dem entwurf
eines gesetzes über die feststellung des
bundes haushaltsplans für das
haushaltsjahr
2022 haushaltsgesetz
2022 einzelplan 04 geschäftsbereich des
bundeskanzlers und des
bundeskanzleramtes drucksachen 20.000 20
16 0 24 16 26 abgegebene stimmkarten
688 mit ja haben gestimmt
391 mit nein haben gestimmt
297 der einzelplan 04 ist somit
angenommen wir fahren fort in der
debatte und als nächstes also nochmal
das ergebnis der namentlichen abstimmung
zum einzelplan vier der hier heute
morgen ab 9
kolleginnen und kollegen der verlauf der
debatte gibt mir noch mal anlass
eingangs zu betonen und festzuhalten das
was wir uns für die gesamte wahlperiode
als cdu csu fraktion auch vorgenommen
haben und was wir versucht haben auch zu
praktizieren
das nämlich bei wahrnehmung der rolle
als oppositionsfraktion wir dennoch in
den zentralen fragen der deutschen
außen- und sicherheitspolitik der
europa-politik die bundesregierung und
die ampel koalition unterstützen das
zeigt auch die heutige debatte auf
abweichungen wird zu sprechen kommen
aber es ist uns wichtig gerade von
diesen beiden fraktionen die sich an den
beiden rändern hier versammelt haben uns
abzugrenzen und zu sagen
deutschland ist das zentrale land in
europa ist ein wichtiges land in europa
europa ist unsere zukunft
das nato ist das sicherheitsbündnis was
uns alle zusammenhält und freiheit und
sicherheit auch für die wunde rick
deutschland gewährleistet und die
internationale regelbasierte ordnung zu
der insbesondere auch die un
menschenrechts charta gehört sind werte
die der gemeinsam als deutsche
verteidigung unter stehen wir in der
demokratischen mitte zusammen
das hat seinen konkreten
ausdruck gefunden dass wir gemeinsam uns
entschlossen haben ein großes paket 100
milliarden paket zu schnüren verbunden
mit einer verfassungsänderung zur
stärkung der bundeswehr und das will ich
auch zu den debatten die wir die wir
dazu geführt haben noch einmal
hinzufügen die verwendung dieser mittel
nur für die bundeswehr war uns wichtig
weil die bundeswehr einen starken
nachholbedarf hatte ich will aber
ausdrücklich dazu sagen dass das was in
der öffentlichen debatte hier und aber
auch in unseren gesprächen von der
außenministerin aber auch von der grünen
fraktion auch von den anderen apple
fraktion immer wieder gesagt oder das
natürlich sicherheit nicht nur in
militärischer stärke besteht sondern
dass wir an den erweiterten erweiterten
sicherheitsbegriff zu verfolgen haben
nachhaltige sicherheit eben nur
herstellen können wenn wir auch
entwicklungspolitik weiter aktiv so
betreiben wie das unter tradition in
deutschland ist wenn wir natürlich auch
cyber abwehr betreiben das ist alles
richtig und das findet alles unsere
vollständige unterstützung auch in
diesem bereich gibt es in der
demokratischen mitte dieses hauses einen
konsens und ich glaube der ist auch
wichtig
dennoch
war es wichtig die bundeswehr an der
stelle zu stärken weil der bundeskanzler
dass heute morgen so auch noch mal
angesprochen hat und darauf hingewiesen
hat dass die union dort die zentrale
verantwortung hat weil sie viele
verteidigungsministerin und minister
gestellt worauf wir stolz waren das ist
das besondere zwei frauen waren in
diesem amt die diese große verantwortung
wahrgenommen haben da haben wir auch in
allen debatten immer wieder gesagt
natürlich ist das auch unsere
verantwortung der zustand der die
bundeswehr jetzt dasteht aber ich muss
sagen von einem bundeskanzler der dieser
debatte jetzt nicht mehr bei wohnt der
finanzminister in der vergangenenen ist
natur periode gewesen ist sich hier
hinzustellen und allein die
verantwortung für die finanzielle
ausstattung der bundeswehr der
unionsfraktion zu geben wird der sache
nicht gerecht die sozialdemokraten und
sozialdemokraten haben mindestens eine
ebensolche verantwortung die haben
manche debatte in den vergangenen jahren
hier geführt wo zum beispiel annegret
kramp karrenbauer gesagt hat sie wünscht
sich zwei prozent und fresken und
damit sie nicht als fraktionsvorsitz
haben mit glatter ablehnung reagiert das
ist die wahrheit meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren sie wir sitzen insofern
in einem boot und das sollte hier nicht
verleugnet werden erst rechtlich vom
regierungschef das war keine gute rolle
heute morgen damit komme ich
insgesamt zu der rolle die die
bundesregierung wahrnimmt und dass
außenministerin hat an vielen stellen
richtiges der sagt die richtigen wert
entscheidung getroffen und insofern
haben wir frau außenministerin baerbock
überhaupt nichts zu kritisieren sondern
unterstützen sie in den zentralen
aussagen die sie in kiew und anderswo
auf der welt getroffen haben zu den
fragen die die freie welt betreffen aber
das urteil können wir für die
bundesregierung insgesamt nicht abgeben
vom side of the free world wie das time
-magazin deutschland noch unter der
leitung von angela merkel bezeichnet hat
sind wir zum sorgenkind geworden und das
hat sieht man schon an der frage der
ukraine und an auch der rede die der
bundeskanzler hier heute gehalten hat zu
konkreten fragen keine antworten was ist
das strategische ziel deutschlands und
des freien europas in dieser nein in
dieser kriegerischen auseinandersetzung
auseinandersetzung wollen wir dass die
ukraine ihre territoriale souveränität
zurück gewinnt das muss doch unsere
gemeinsame auffassung sein dass hatte
bundeskanzler wieder heute nicht gesagt
in dieser debatte
keine konkrete antwort auf die
waffenlieferungen die notwendig sind
wieder die ankündigung eines neuen
komplexen systems auch den g partner hat
er heute gesagt in drei wochen
ausbildung da sage ich nur von andy als
jemand der ein paar jahren der
truppengattung gedient hat in drei
wochen jemanden am gepard auszubilden
ist völlig unverantwortlich und völlig
ausgeschlossen noch nicht mal in drei
monaten ist das möglich jetzt wird ein
neues system angeboten es wird ein neues
system angeboten mag man in einigen
monaten auch liefern aber heute könnten
schützenpanzer geliefert werden sie hat
schon vor einem monat geliefert werden
seit einem monat führt die
bundesregierung nicht das durch was wir
alle von ihr erwartet haben nämlich der
ukraine jetzt und hier zu helfen das ist
ein schwerer historischer fehler
anna lässt die ukraine in einem die die
worte übrigens in davos fand ich auch
völlig unangemessen es ist nicht so dass
putin strategische ziele nicht erreicht
sondern die ukraine verliert gerade und
hat größte verluste und darunter leidet
zivilbevölkerung und das ist
unterlassene hilfeleistung von der
bundesregierung und ein verstoß gegen
bundestagsbeschlüsse das lassen wir
ihnen so nicht durchgehen und es fehlt
auch jede antwort auf die europäische
zukunft es fehlt jede antwort darauf ob
das hat der bundeskanzler heute auch
nicht gesagt ob denn nun der
kandidatenstatus angestrebt wird und
natürlich ist es formal so dass der dass
dazu die kommission einen vorschlag
macht aber sie haben sich in ihren
eigenen ampel koalitionsvertrag
hineingeschrieben dass sie vorangehen
wollen dass sie dazu vorschläge
unterbreiten wollen und es ist natürlich
notwendig dass deutschland als das
größte land hier vorangeht und sagt was
es will wenn deutschland nicht sagt dass
es an der seite der ukraine ist dann
werden erst recht viele andere in europa
nicht folgen und hier versagt die
bundesregierung hier wäre führung
notwendig und deswegen
in vielen kleinen entfielen konkreten
reden manches richtige die große linie
in der außenpolitik fehlt deutschland
ist zum sorgenkind geworden und das wird
die anforderung der nächsten zeit seien
von außenministerin da kommt auf sie in
der bundesregierung eine große
verantwortung zu in vielem haben sie
gute ansätze gezeigt daran werden wir
sie unterstützen aber der bundeskanzler
der muss seine rolle in der außenpolitik
noch finden danke
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende johann wadephul hat
hier unter anderem die cyber abwehr
angesprochen ursprünglich wollten
besonders die grünen auch das
sondervermögen bundeswehr nutzen um die
cyber abwehr zu stärken
gegen konnte sich durchsetzen dieses
sondervermögen wird dafür nicht genutzt
und jetzt die bundes außenministerin
kolleginnen und kollegen die für
schülerinnen und schüler sehr viele
heute hier auf der tribüne ich möchte
mich zuallererst herzlich bedanken das
haben ja einige von ihnen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen auch schon
gemacht in dieser besonderen situation
die insbesondere diesen haushalt
besonders herausgefordert hat haben wir
haben sie gemeinsam zusammengearbeitet
und das ist wirklich bemerkenswert wir
konnten gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass
insbesondere die humanitäre hilfe
deutlich um 35 millionen gerade auch für
die ukraine erhöht worden ist dafür
meine herzlichsten dank
möchte war gleich zu beginn auch sagen
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen dass
wir das noch länger tun müssen
zusammenstehen aber vor allen dingen
gerade im auswärtigen zusätzliche mittel
bereitzustellen
denn der russische präsident hat seine
strategie offensichtlich fundamental
verändert er hat anfangs gedacht er
marschiert ganz schnell ein und nimmt
die ukraine ein und dann ist alles
vorbei das war zum glück nicht
erfolgreich aber deswegen lässt setzt er
jetzt darauf dass er einen längeren atem
hat als wir die die ukraine unterstützer
längeren atem als die ukraine und vor
allen dingen ersetzt auf mehr brutale
gewalt und natürlich kann man da sagen
wir verschließen die augen wie das die
linke hier gerade noch einmal
unterstrichen hat wir schauen einfach
weg und tun so als würde es das alles
nicht geben die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer können aber nicht wegschauen
auf sie fallen tagtäglich bomben in ihre
städte und dörfer rollen tagtäglich
panzer ein und wenn sie sich diese
fernsehbilder anschauen und ja ich
glaube das ist richtig dass wir das tun
dann sehen wir gerade im don was statt
fisch statt dorf für dorf wird von
russischen truppen aus sicherer
entfernung
dem erdboden gleich gemacht weil es ist
eine neue strategie es kommen erst die
raketen dann die flugzeuge mit
artillerie und dann wenn alles schon
platt ist rollen die panzer ein und wir
müssen uns ehrlich machen das ist eine
neue vernichtungs welle und das bedeutet
es ist auch eine strategie der
entvölkerung der auslöschung der
zivilisation im dom was man will die
staatlichkeit dort zerstören und
deswegen müssen wir heute hier aus
meiner sicht klar und deutlich sagen wir
schauen eben nicht weg wir machen es uns
nicht einfach und sagen wir wünschen uns
mal es gäbe kein krieg nein wir
verteidigen die menschen in der ukraine
so wie wir das können mit
waffenlieferungen das heißt wir brauchen
erstens einen langen atem bei der
unterstützung der ukraine
und wir brauchen jetzt weitere
waffenlieferungen und das heißt vor
allen dingen artillerie drohnen und
flugabwehr und wir sind da gemeinsam mit
unseren partnern dran wir haben das ja
schon mehrfach diskutiert warum manches
etwas länger dauert auch da möchte ich
einmal deutlich sagen es dauert halt
länger weil es nichts bringt einfach zu
sagen wir versprechen euch wir schicken
was sondern das zeug muss auch ankommen
und vor allen dingen müssen die
soldatinnen und soldaten dass auch
bedienen können und ich frage das
richtig dass auch immer wieder kritisch
hinterfragt wurde warum wird denn nur
altes ausrangiertes militärisches
material geschickt die ukraine hat uns
darum gebeten vor allem hoch modernere
systeme zu schicken und genau das tun
wir jetzt deswegen werden wir ein boden
luftverteidigungssystem iris t in die
ukraine liefern und sie hatten vorher
einberufen aber das dauert dann wieder
ja das dauert und zwar monate weil es
ist das modernste was es überhaupt gibt
das sollte eigentlich ein anderes land
geben wir haben uns dafür eingesetzt
dass darauf verzichtet wird und dass
jetzt in der ukraine geben kann weil es
braucht auch diese mittel und
langfristigen signale dass wir eben
nicht in drei monaten die ukraine
aufgegeben haben sondern dass wir
dauerhaft verteidigen so wie wir das
können
ohne uns selbst an diesen krieg zu
beteiligen
und ich möchte auch noch mal deutlich
sagen so geht es doch allen hier im saal
jeder mit herz und verstand der wünscht
sich doch nichts sehnlicher als dass
dieser brutale angriffskrieg endlich
vorbei ist ich meine wer zum teufel
wünscht sich krieg niemand alle wollen
in frieden leben aber
wir können doch oft von vergewaltigung
wir können doch oft von kriegsverbrechen
nicht sagen wir haben euch mal die
daumen gedrückt leider ist es
schiefgegangen wenn wir damit aufhören
wenn wir mit dem ende der solidarität
für die verteidigungs aufhören wenn wir
unsere militärische unterstützung
einstellen würden und genau das fordern
sie ja von der linken und auch von der
afd wenn sie wenn sie sagen würden ja
jetzt sollten wir mal auf putin hinzu
kommen sollten wir doch mal der für
enten stattfinden lassen wir haben das
in nachbarländern der ukraine gesehen
dass ein ende der gewalt eben nicht
automatisch freiheit bedeutet sondern im
zweifel genau das gegenteil und wenn wir
das akzeptierten oder auch nur
suggerieren wir würden das tun ehrlich
gesagt würden wir alles verraten wofür
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer gekämpft
haben würden wir die zivilistinnen und
zivilisten verraten und herr gysi jetzt
sind sie gar nicht mehr da da da hinten
danke das freut mich umso mehr weil ich
glaube man muss sich mit solchen
argumenten auseinandersetzen man habe
auch über jahre versucht autokraten ein
bisschen zuckerbrot und peitsche zu
geben und sie haben jetzt gesagt mich
aufgefordert mann soll mit blick auf die
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china den
uiguren soll man sagen wir bieten euch
was an das fordert auch jeden heraus wir
machen noch mal ein paar mehr
menschenrechtsverletzung dann kriegt man
vielleicht auch noch einen bonus
obendrauf
unterscheiden zwischen ruhig
unterscheidet nicht zwischen ihnen
verfolgten russischen journalisten und
menschenrechtsverteidiger inzwischen 47
oder kunden das erste auch die stärke
der menschenrechte und teilbarkeit egal
an welchem flexten der welt ist mein den
vom minister haben sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der afc fraktion indes
wegen verteidigen wir hier gemeinsam
auch unsere europäische friedensordnung
das internationale recht und ja all
diejenigen die sagen warme worte reichen
nicht aus sage ich auch sehr deutlich
die ukraine verteidigt nicht nur unsere
europäische friedensordnung die ukraine
braucht eine europäische perspektive und
es ist richtig dass die kommission für
alle staaten da einen vorschlag macht
weil unsere stärkste waffe in diesem
moment ist die europäische
geschlossenheit die europäische
geschlossenheit aller europäischen
länder gemeinsam für die ukraine und den
westlichen balkan
darüber hinaus ist aber klar
mehr militärische fähigkeiten allein
werden nicht reichen um in dieser
gefährlichen neuen welt zu bestehen das
ist vollkommen klar russland führt auch
einen hybriden krieg einkorn krieg ein
krieg mit desinformation und deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass in diesem haus
hat und wie gesagt wirklich herzlicher
dank dafür auch mittel für cyber für
krisen vorsorgen für ertüchtigung für
stabilisierung deutlich deutlich
gestärkt worden sind das ist die
humanitäre hilfe mit 27 milliarden euro
und die geht eben nicht nur in die
ukraine die geht in den saal nach syrien
in den jemen nach afghanistan wo die
menschen nicht mehr wissen was sie
abends ihren kindern eigentlich zu essen
geben können und diese mittel werden wir
in zukunft weiter erhöhen müssen dass es
auch mein wunsch das ist mein
eindringlicher appell wenn wir in ein
paar wochen wieder über den haushalt
verhandeln wir brauchen mehr und jetzt
wurde gerade gesagt sie wissen gar nicht
wohin das geld geht so schön im
ausschuss die einrede und hier die
andere rede aber wer
unicef die ganzen internationalen
programme der vereinten nationen dahin
geht unsere humanitäre hilfe weil es
geht nicht darum dass ließen sich auf
die brust klopfen und sagen dann die
deutsche außenministerin hatte gehen
jens geht es dass die mittel auch daran
kommen zum beispiel afghanistan so wird
zu recht als deutsche wie präsent sind
aber unicef die kinder vor ort versorgen
kann und das bedeutet für uns eine werte
basierte außenpolitik heißt sicherheit
ist mehr als nur die abwesenheit von
krieg es bedeutet gebend auch
investitionen in bildungsarbeit in
menschenrechtsarbeit und es bedeutet
auch pragmatisch zu sein in den
entscheidenden momenten zu handeln das
ist unsere gemeinsame lehrer auch aus
afghanistan und daher möchte ich hier
einmal sehr deutlich sagen in dem moment
wo uns auch russische bürgerinnen und
bürger gebraucht haben journalistinnen
menschenrechtsverteidiger haben wir ganz
pragmatisch gehandelt und gesagt ihr
könnt ohne bürokratische hürden nach
deutschland kommt und da hat jemand
eindringlicher appell auch im namen der
bundesinnenministerium an alle
bundesländer lassen sie uns diese
menschen nicht im stich lassen auch sie
sind mutig gegen putin aufgestanden
sie brauchen eine deutsche perspektive
hier in sicherheit leben zu können wir
senden damit mit diesem haushalt ein
klares signal an unsere partnerinnen und
partner
deutschland übernimmt außenpolitische
verantwortung
aufwerten und entschlossenheit und vor
allen dingen unsere partnerinnen und
partner können sich auf uns verlassen
danke dass wir das gemeinsam tun als
demokratinnen und demokraten
bundesaußenminister von annalena
baerbock hat hier ihren kurs verteidigt
und auch den kurs der bundesregierung
und hat sich auch zum beispiel gregor
gysi noch einmal zugewandte sich ja
deutlich der sich deutlich über ihre
haltung hier beschwert hatte stefan
kräuter spricht als nächstes für die
fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren sehr geehrte frau
außenministerin ich hatte hier
eigentlich eine haushaltsrede erwartet
aber dass sie ist eine so ausgewiesene
militärexperten sind hätte ich nicht für
möglich gehalten
fangen wir mal mit ihrer
wertorientierten und feministischen
außenpolitik an wenn ich mit
mitarbeitern ihres hauses zusammentreffe
frage ich einfach mal was ist eigentlich
eine feministische außenpolitik das löst
bei den kollegen von ihnen
schweißtropfen auf der stirn aus und es
geht mit individual- definitionen los
ganz nach dem motto von pippi
langstrumpf ich mach mir die welt
widdewidde wie sie mir gefällt ich habe
dann mal im internet nachgeguckt bei
wikipedia ist die definition
feministische außenpolitik gezeigt wird
ein konzept beziehungsweise an prinzip
im rahmen internationaler außenpolitik
bei dem feministischen sichtweisen zum
maßstab gemacht werden da frage ich sie
wie diskriminierend ist das denn wo
bleiben denn da die männer und das von
ihnen geforderte dritte geschlecht
sie votieren hier am ende noch von einer
außenministerin zur amazonenkönigin
die geschlechtergerechtigkeit das ist
doch ein alter wein in neuen schläuchen
die wird auch in diesem land links
gelähmt wir von der afg fordern wieder
eine interessengeleitete außenpolitik
welche die interessen des deutschen
volkes in den mittelpunkt stellt und
verfolgt wir sprechen hier aber über den
haushalt sie versuchen natürlich auch
einzusparen wenn ich mir das anschaue
die forderungen deutscher minderheiten
in mittel und osteuropa erfährt eine
kürzung um 50 prozent wenn sie mich
fragen ist das ansetzen des rotstifts es
an der falschen stelle das sind die
mittler unserer sprache und kultur im
ausland
gemeinsam mit der verteidigung darin
versuchen sie allerdings jetzt die
ukraine mit 2 milliarden euro deutsches
steuergeld zu ertüchtigen
da frage ich sie welche deutschen
interessen verfolgen sie in diesem hoch
korrupten ehemaligen sowjetstaat und um
welchen preis wenn es ihnen ernst ist
machen sie ein loft doch ein angebot
einstellungen der kriegshandlungen gegen
einstellung der sanktionen und
abstimmung der strittig oder
volksabstimmungen in den strittigen
regionen unter internationaler
beobachtung und anerkennung wenn sie so
weitsichtig wären dann könnten sie hier
konfliktpotenziale in südossetien
transnistrien abchasien und in der
republik aspx raska gleich in diesem
sinne mit verhandeln und weiteres
blutvergießen vermeiden wenn sie ein
echtes interesse an einer lösung dieses
konfliktes hätten
ich habe aber ich habe respekt vor ihrem
mut sie verschleiern nicht einmal die
verschaffung von versorgungsposten um
die versorgung ihrer lobbyisten
jahrzehntelang kam das auswärtige amt
mit zwei angestellten also beamteten und
zwei parlamentarischen staatssekretären
aus
2017 musste dann die frau bär von der
csu versorgt wurden werden dafür erhielt
dann die spd einen hübschen
staatsminister posten für form und
fehring mit allen folgekosten
2021 hätten sie die möglichkeit gehabt
dies wieder rückgängig zu machen
stattdessen darf sich jetzt ein grüner
abgeordneter
staatsminister im auswärtigen amt nennen
aber damit nicht genug jetzt kommt auch
noch jennifer morgen von greenpeace die
dritte staatssekretär stelle im
auswärtigen amt wird geschaffen
verbunden mit einer blitz einbürgerung
und lebenslangen versorgungsanspruch ich
habe mich mit frau morgen mal
unterhalten als sie ganz euphorisch von
einer reise nach bangladesch tiere zum
thema klima klima klima berichtete ich
habe sie dann nach der problematik der
rohingya gefragt wo anderthalb millionen
menschen in flüchtlingscamps sitzen oder
schwemmland inseln umgesiedelt werden
sollen von morgen war in bangladesch und
wusste mit dem thema ruin ja noch nicht
etwas an zu fangen das ist eine
katastrophe für eine deutsche
staatsminister bzw staatssekretärin
lassen sie uns zum schluss noch ganz
kurz über die ortskräfte in afghanistan
sprechen frau berben eine anfrage ihrer
fraktion der grünen und der afg hat
ergeben dass es 2000 echte ortskräfte
gab ihr vorgänger im amt rechnete mit
fünf familienangehörigen ports kraft
sind 12.000 personen jetzt sitzt in
islamabad 50.000 menschen 30.000
afghanen auf der sogenannten a ha liste
20.000 auf der bmi liste das sind
insgesamt 50.000 die können sich in
islamabad visa abholen gegebenenfalls
noch reise ausweise für ausländer sie
fliegen hier menschen teilweise die
herkunft völlig unklar ist in unserem
land ein mit mehreren maschinen
wöchentlich das werden wir weiter im
auge behalten und aufarbeiten vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit und frau
berbalk politisch werden die sie weiter
jagen vielen dank
stefan kreuzer war das für die fdp
fraktion hat unter anderem die stelle
von michelle müntefering in der
vergangenen legislaturperiode
kritisiert und sie spricht jetzt hier
als abgeordnete in dieser debatte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich sag mal
vorweg vielleicht gibt das dem einen
oder anderen dieser seite zu denken
frauenrechte sind menschenrechte und
menschenrechte den frauen recht
außenpolitik außenpolitik ist auf jeden
fall nichts zum zuschauen demokratie und
multilateralismus brauchen den einsatz
eines jeden von uns und putins krieg
bedeutet auch deswegen eine zäsur für
unsere außenpolitik weil seine brutale
angriff auf die ukraine die zivilen
errungenschaften der macht gilt zum fraß
vorwirft der bruch des internationalen
rechts auf brutale weise die größte
stärke ja lieber anderen in hamburg bei
außenministerin die wir dem
entgegensetzen können ist die
geschlossenheit unserer antwort
international und auch hier im parlament
und deswegen kann ich nur all diejenigen
auffordern auch die die noch
unentschlossen sind zum sondervermögen
setzen wir auf ein starkes zeichen aus
deutschland auf den klaren willen auch
in die verteidigung unserer überzeugung
zu investieren sie zu schützen gerade
auch mit einer handlungsfähigen
bundeswehr liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen partnerschaft die einfache
übersetzung von multilateralismus
bedeutet immer auch verantwortung und
deutschland hatte verantwortung in
europa und der welt und das heißt auch
dass wir einander beistehen wir unseren
partnern sowie wir auf den beistand
anderer zählen und das sind keine
einfachen zeiten die folgen des
klimawandels hunger ungleichheit eine
pandemie fordern uns der angriffskrieg
russland als tiefpunkt europäischer
nachkriegsgeschichte hat weitere
auswirkungen heute in gänze kaum
abzusehen und er zeigt auf dramatische
weise leider auch dass die lesart dieses
eklatanten bruch des völkerrechts nicht
überall auf der welt gleich ist als
interfraktionelle delegation bei der mpu
der welt parlamentarier konferenz
angeführt von ralph brinkhaus haben wir
das von einem vor einigen wochen erlebt
afrika und asien wachsen immens und
gleichzeitig zielt die russische
propaganda vor allem in diese teile der
welt der globale system wettbewerb hat
an schärfe gewonnen und auch in
demokratien sehen wir tiefe spaltungen
in gesellschaften und unsere mehr es ist
heute aufgabe von diplomatie auch
diejenigen zu überzeugen die nicht
selbstverständlich auf der straße der
demokratie fahren und das bedeutet ja
auch in außenpolitik in diplomatie zu
investieren und angesichts der
weltweiten krisen liegt der
haushalterische schwerpunkt des
auswärtigen amtes in diesem jahr neben
den investitionen in das diplomatische
netzwerk auf der humanitären hilfe mit
2,7 milliarden euro macht sie ein
drittel des etat von rund 7,5 milliarden
euro aus aber als vorsitzender des
unterausschusses für die auswärtigen
kultur und bildungsbereich auf diesen
bereich hervorheben die akw bleibt eine
wichtige säule der deutschen
außenpolitik und im zuge der
parlamentarischen beratungen zum
haushalt wurde die erhöhung auf über
eine milliarde euro beschlossen wir
erreichen also die kultur milliarde und
die brauchen wir auch weiterhin zu dem
was wir an anderen stellen investieren
das ist eine gute nachricht
ich sage aber auch ohne den deutlichen
willen des bundestages und
fraktionsübergreifende unterstützung der
das nicht möglich gewesen und deswegen
danke auch von mir an alle kolleginnen
und kollegen die geholfen haben und ganz
besonders die bw papenburg die heute von
zu hause aus zu sieht und ihr kind
erwartet alles gute dir und deiner
familie
danke dass sie sich
sind bereiche friedenspolitik einsätzen
für unsere mittlerorganisationen das
goethe institut den deutschen
akademischen austauschdienst das
institut für auslandsbeziehungen die
deutsche welle das archäologische
institut oder die alexander von humboldt
stiftung und die auslandsschulen die so
wichtige arbeit leisten
aber warum setzt der bundestag gerade
hier gemeinsam ein zeichen was bedeuten
euro hier in zeiten des krieges in
europa kultur und bildung in der
außenpolitik die antwort ist relativ
einfach wir wissen dass auch jenseits
der diplomatie der verteidigung und der
multilateralen organisationen die es zu
stärken gilt sich viel gutes bewegen
lässt einen beitrag dazu dass wir die
kurve noch kriegen bevor unser planet
komplett in schutt und asche liegt und
dafür brauchen wir den austausch der
menschen begegnungen junger das
potenzial kreativer und nicht zuletzt
eine lebendige debatte darüber wie wir
in dieser welt leben wollen weil wir es
langfristig nur so schaffen als
menschheit auf diesen planeten zu
überleben wenn wir zivilisierte
diskussionen ermöglichen und austausch
und demokratie brauchen offenheit die
schützenswert und leider noch nicht
überall selbstverständlich ist viel zu
oft ist sie sogar lebensgefährlich und
deswegen werden wir die schutzprogramme
für künstler wissenschaftlerinnen
ausweiten ein neues für verfolgter
journalistinnen
errichten und mit der selber initiative
menschenrechtsaktivistinnen unterstützen
aus der ukraine aus belarus und russland
danke auch dafür diejenigen die sich
einsetzen für frieden und freiheit die
werden wir unterstützen und ihn mit den
mitteln auch der ak w p unter die arme
greifen denn wir sehen in unserer
nachbarschaft will eine junge generation
in freiheit frieden und demokratie leben
und sich eben nicht unterdrücken lassen
und den diskurs mit osteuropa den wollen
wir vertiefen auch mit dem programm
östliche partnerschaft und wir denken
aufwand osman kavala einen brückenbauer
zwischen der türkei und deutschland der
hinter gittern sitzt und freigelassen
gehört liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
aus der politik ist nichts zum thema
demokratie braucht uns alle darum geht's
die grossen verschiebungen der macht sie
passieren jetzt und sie gehen auch
einher mit gezielter desinformation
autokratische systeme und deswegen muss
auch die strategische kommunikation ganz
oben auf die tagesordnung des
auswärtigen amtes den wunsch verbinde
ich mit dem herzlichen dank an alle
kolleginnen und kollegen im
diplomatischen dienst an sie liebe frau
außenministerin annalena baerbock und
ich will schließen mit einer
mit einem zitat beziehungsweise at mit
etwas anders präsident selensky gerade
erinnert hat in cannes bei dem großen
film festival der hatte gesagt wir
brauchen einen neuen champion und ich
habe daraufhin die rede am schluss der
film des films der große diktator noch
mal nachgelesen und da heißt es zu denen
die mich hören können sage ich
verzweifeln sie nicht das elend das
jetzt über uns kommt ist nur das
vorgehen der gier die bitterkeit der
menschen die den weg des menschlichen
fortschritts fürchten der hass der
menschen wird vergehen diktatoren
sterben und die macht die sie den
menschen genommen haben wir zu den
menschen zurückkehren herzlichen dank
michelle müntefering war das hier in der
debatte zum auswärtigen amts im
einzelplan 05 71 milliarden euro sollen
dem auswärtigen amt zur verfügung stehen
oder schlechte spricht nun dazu
außenpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
gesagt hat man kennt mich in der politik
eigentlich nur als oli aber da steht
natürlich dann der richtige vorn habe
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir reden hier
über den ersten bundeshaushalt seit der
zeitenwende vom 24 februar und der
völkerrechtswidrige russische
angriffskrieg in der ukraine hat vieles
infrage gestellt was wir vorher als
sicher angenommen hatten viele neue
synapsen werden derzeit gebildet die
leidtragenden des trägers sind
hauptsächlich die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer aber die auswirkung dieses
krieges spüren die leute auch
hierzulande putins krieg ist vor allem
ein angriff auf das ukrainische volk er
ist aber auch ein angriff auf die
regelbasierte internationale ordnung
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
gemeinsam in der eu der nato und der g7
und darüber hinaus zusammenstehen um
putin grenzen zu setzen der
angriffskrieg darf sich nicht lohnen
denn sonst wird er sich angebots
anderswo wiederholen das kostet uns
jetzt geld aber das ist das wert denn
der verlust der regelbasierten
internationalen ordnung wäre langfristig
deutlich teurer
im haushalt des auswärtigen amts liegt
der größte kriegsbedingte aufwuchs bei
den mitteln für humanitäre hilfe dort
haben wir das budget von 2 milliarden
auf knapp 2 5 milliarden angehoben
meinen herzlichsten dank gilt allen
haushältern die das uns ermöglicht haben
stellvertretend für die haushälter von
der fdp otto fricke und michael link
dass ihr das mit euren kollegen zusammen
geschafft hat der mehrbedarf
ergibt sich nicht nur aus der
humanitären hilfe die ukraine selbst
sondern auch durch die blockierte
ukrainische weizen aus vor die zu einer
akuten
lebensmittelkrise unter anderem
nordafrika und dem saal für
preissteigerungen von bis zu 150 prozent
bei den ärmsten der armen der welt eine
erneute flüchtlingskrise und das müsste
eigentlich auch der afg klar sein gilt
es im unbekannten dimensionen mit allen
mitteln zu verhindern neben der erhöhung
der mittel für humanitäre hilfe konnten
wir mit einem haushalts vermerk
sicherstellen dass mindestens 30 prozent
der gelder als flexible mittel gezahlt
werden so wie es die bundesregierung 1
2016 beim humanitären weltgipfel von
istanbul im grand bonn zugesagt hatte so
befreien wir nämlich die
hilfsorganisation von unnötiger
bürokratie und geben ihnen den
handlungsspielraum den sie dringend
benötigen die hebelwirkung von freien
mitteln ist nämlich enorm und die
auswirkungen des russischen
angriffskrieges betreffen nicht nur den
klassischen bereich der auswärtigen
politik er betrifft auch andere bereiche
von der verteidigung über die energie
bis zur finanzpolitik da ist es umso
wichtiger dass wir nun eine
ressortübergreifende nationale
sicherheitsstrategie erarbeiten
zusätzlich zu dieser nationalen
sicherheitsstrategie wird es auch eine
neue china strategie geben denn auch
china missachtet völkerrechtliche
vereinbarung vom südchinesische meer
über hongkong des nach zehn young und
stellt so ebenfalls die regelbasierte
internationale ordnung in frage china
schaut ganz genau auf die reaktion der
internationalen gemeinschaft auf den
russischen angriffskrieg um zu sehen wie
wir auf eine chinesische invasion in
taiwan reagieren könnten die shootings
schon mehrfach angedroht hat und den
startschuss damit um die machtfrage im
pazifik bedeuten würde auch deshalb
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass sich der
angriffskrieg in der ukraine für putin
nicht auszahlt letzter satz wenn wir den
krieg schon nicht verhindern konnten
meine damen und herren
dann lassen sie uns wenigstens dafür
sorgen dass der krieg auf dieser welt
nicht schule machen kann vielen dank
aus der unionsfraktion spricht nun
ingenieurs thermischen sieht er ist
sprecher für menschenrechte und
humanitäre hilfe seiner fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der bundeshaushalt wird in
einer historisch einmaligen phase
beraten wir befinden uns in einem
historischen umbruch in diesem umbruch
in dieser neuen ära muss sich die
deutsche außenpolitik neun fragen
stellen mit alten rezepten auch mit dem
alten appeasement auch nicht mit der
alten konzeption der europäischen union
die probleme zumeist mit geld zudeckt
kommen wir nicht mehr weiter das spüren
wir auch alles und zur menschenrechts
basierten außenpolitik die ist immer
konkret das heißt es darf keine
doppelten standards geben weder im
umgang mit karte und ist braucht einen
deutsch chinesischen
menschenrechtsdialog auf augenhöhe
angesichts eines brutalen
vernichtungsfeldzug gegen die
minderheiten wie die ohren und die
tibeter
vor allem geht es aber in dieser
zeitenwende in dieser großen gefahr für
europa um menschenrechte stabilität und
verlässlichkeit ohne verlässlichkeit
ohne glaubwürdigkeit der handelnden
akteure werden wir die existenzielle
gefahr für unseren kontinent nicht
abwenden allerdings und das muss ich
nach vielen internationalen kontakten
den letzten wochen bekennen ist durch
das zynische taktieren der
bundesregierung zur hilfe für die
bedrohte ukraine mit immer neuen
überzeugenden immer fadenscheinigen
manövern ein katastrophaler
vertrauensverlust für deutschland
eingetreten der zudem die
glaubwürdigkeit europas massiv
beschädigt
diese massive beschädigung hat die
selbst die seltsam dünnhäutige rede
heute des bundeskanzlers nicht
reparierte gegenteil man konnte es ja
quasi anfassen hier stimmt etwas nicht
hier wird nicht glaubwürdig gehandelt
wenn das wort des größten eu-landes
deutschlands nicht mehr gilt fällt
europa als wesentlicher akteur zur
sicherung des friedens aus diese haltung
schwächt die jungen dieser krise
existenziell weil die bundesregierung
sich wegen innerparteilicher besonders
die proteste gerade aus ihren reihen kam
wegen innerparteilichen debatten in der
spd weigert aggression und völkermord
effektiv in die schranken zu weisen und
das ist ein gefährliches spiel mit dem
kontinent europa
und dieses zynische spiel läuft ja vor
den augen der ganzen welt aber auch wenn
einige hier diese bittere wahrheit nicht
vertragen können sie alle haben
geschworen schaden vom deutschen volke
abzuwenden
dazu zählt nach unserer staatsräson dass
wir völkermord und angriffskrieg nicht
noch einmal zulassen gerade die spd hat
immer wieder erklärt nie wieder
faschismus nie wieder krieg auch die spd
wird einen hohen preis für diesen
glaubwürdigkeitsverlust bezahlen wer
heute der ukraine für jedermann ja
erkennbar die nötige und mögliche hilfe
verweigert und auch noch behauptet man
würde alle mögliche hilfe leisten der
versagt nicht nur in den augen der opfer
er schadet auch dem nationalen interesse
der bundesrepublik deutschland und
verletzt seinen amtseid
die folgen spüren wir jetzt schon der
bundeskanzler wird in wenigen tagen für
einen kurzbesuch auf dem balkan reisen
schon jetzt gilt es reicht nicht mehr
dass ein europäischer spitzenpolitiker
dort die nase kurz in die tür stecken
und sagt wir sind mit euch
insbesondere dieser bundeskanzler wird
es schwer haben weil bei vielen sein
wort nicht mehr geld der krieg in der
ukraine bedroht millionen in anderen
kontinenten mit dem hungertod die
humanitäre hilfe muss darauf eine
entschlossene und auch eine gewichtige
antwort finden die außenministerin wird
im anschluss an diese debatte im
ausschuss für menschenrechte und
humanitäre hilfe zu gast sein dort
werden wir über die konkreten schritte
gegen die geiselnahme der hungernden in
der welt durch den kriegsverbrecher
putin sprechen die vom hungertod
bedrohten brauchen keine leeren
solidaritätsadressen sondern konkrete
aktion ich weiß und ich schätze
ausdrücklich dass die bundesministerin
nicht zu den siegern zählt und hier
alles versucht was möglich ist erlauben
sie eine zwischenfrage aus der spd
deshalb geht an uns alle besonders an
die spd zu hören hilft auch manchmal in
diesem parlament der appell dass wir
bereit bleiben zu besonderen maßnahmen
auch im bundeshaushalt um eine
katastrophe abzuwenden
frau ministerin berbalk hat das gerade
beschrieben wenn wir uns insgesamt in
dieser historischen gefährdung des
friedens auf unserem kontinent und
darüber hinaus nicht bewähren wenn wir
mutlos bleiben wenn wir zu den richtigen
entscheidungen unfähig bleiben dann
droht uns das ende des projekts europa
als frieden zuordnung ist braucht kluges
sorgfältiges und von verantwortung und
nicht von feigheit getriebenen
getriebenes überlegen und vor allem
braucht es rasches und richtiges
entscheiden dazu zählt eine echte nicht
nur rhetorische einladung zur eu
beitrittsverhandlungen für die länder
des westlichen balkans für serbien
zugeständnis nur dann wenn er sich
endlich von putin löst für die ukraine
und die moldau und eine strategische
debatte und eine neuausrichtung mit der
global größten gefahr china ist
überfällig darauf hoffe ich und dafür
stehen wir als union bereit vielen dank
einen katastrophalen vertrauensverlust
hat hier michael brandt ausgemacht und
jetzt gibt es eine kurzintervention aus
der spd-fraktion weil keine
zwischenfragen zugelassen
gefragt mit wieviel abgeordneten aus
anderen europäischen ländern sie in den
letzten drei monaten diskutiert haben
über die deutsche politik sie haben die
zwischenfragen zugelassen ich beantworte
sie von mir aus ich habe mit kollegen
kriegbaum zusammen in den letzten drei
monaten insgesamt fünf sitzungen in der
zukunftskonferenz europas mit
parlamentariern parlamentariern aus 27
ländern diskutiert das was sie erzählt
haben über die wahrnehmung von
deutschland politik die beschämung die
sie hier getan hat die sie hier
vorgetragen hat wird dort fast nirgendwo
unterstützt das was sie sagen ist eine
fata morgana
axel schäfer aus der spd-fraktion
pendants
rechten sehr wieder
[Applaus]
herr kollege schäfer tag an den sie sich
eigentlich nur kurz darauf antworten
wenn sie mir nicht glauben wollen der
unionsfraktion dann sollten sie auch
stimmen in ihrer eigenen koalition hören
auf fr strack zimmermann im übrigen auch
auf die außenministerin die ganz andere
akzente gesetzt hat als der
bundeskanzler oder auch an toni
hofreiter wo sie ihre
gesprächspartner her haben und ob sie
überhaupt nationale und internationale
zeitungen lesen das würde ich sie gerne
zurück fragen sie sind ziemlich allein
in der einschätzung über die konsequenz
der außenpolitik des bundeskanzlers ich
muss sagen ich schäme mich dafür dass er
sich so national und international vor
allen dingen wegduckt und vor allen
dingen nicht das tut was er sagt
soweit also die kurzintervention unter
anderem zum thema waffenlieferungen gibt
es ja tatsächlich auch innerhalb der
koalition unterschiedliche auffassungen
beziehungsweise auch schon stimmen die
zu mir eine rufen jürgen trittin jens
für die bündnisgrünen
[Applaus]
es ist eine zeitenwende wir sind
konfrontiert damit dass die einst von
der sowjetunion unter leonid breschnew
mit geschaffene friedens und sicherheit
ordnung in europa durch putin zerstört
wird und die konsequenz daraus scheint
bei ihnen und euch noch nicht richtig
angekommen zu sein aber gerade wenn ich
das sage dass es um die europäische
friedens- und sicherheitsrat angeht
da muss sich davor warnen den begriff
zeitenwende
eurozentristisch zu betrachten wenn man
darüber mit anderen spricht dann wird
auf verschiedene dinge verwiesen zur
zeitenwende gehört
dass in indien im mai über 50 grad
temperatur war dass die klimakrise
mittlerweile dazu geführt hat in sri
lanka eine regierung zu stürzen
dazu gehört es dass am horn von afrika
der fünfte sommer droht wo es nicht
regnet wo menschen verhungern vor
laufender kamera zur zeitenwende gehört
auch dass er mit manchen menschen auf
der vergangenheit aufhören müssen die
idee dass eine globalisierung
funktioniert die nur nach den
günstigsten kosten standort funktioniert
und dass man dabei nicht auf
menschenrechte und ähnliches gucken muss
die ist gescheitert und am sichtbarsten
am sichtbarsten es sie gescheitert wenn
man sich anschaut wie gestörte
lieferketten da sind und was wir folgen
aus diesen krisen und der krieg im
aggressions krieg kommen inflation
weltweit steigende energiepreise und
eine anhaltende weizen krise darauf gibt
es keine einfache antworten diese
regierung versucht darauf antworten zu
geben ja
wir liefern schwachen auch schweres
gerät in die ukraine aber nein lieber
michael
wir machen schluss damit in
völkerrechtswidrige kriege waffen rhein
zu liegen wie es ihre koalition in
richtung saudi-arabien vor dem
hintergrund des jemen krieges jahre lang
gemacht haben das gehört zusammen zur
zeitenwende ja
und wir glauben auch nicht dass wandel
alleine handeln allein wandel schafft
diese regierung ist hingegangen und hat
gesagt wir beenden zum ersten mal
investitionsgarantien für investitionen
dienten sie an stattfinden ja wir wollen
nicht aus der globalisierung
verabschieden aber wir wollen
globalisierung gestalten und zum
gestalten der globalisierung gehört es
auch menschenrechtliche standards unter
anderem durch solche maßnahmen
durchzusetzen und letzte bemerkten
war diese haushalte nur gut neun im
ersten entwurf nicht da fehlten bei dem
zivilen mitteln der internationalen
zusammenarbeit 3,5 milliarden davon
haben wir dank der haushälter fiel
wieder rausgekriegt aber ich fühle auch
einzeln zu diese zeitenwende ist 2022
nicht zu ende und ich erwarte von dieser
bundesregierung von dieser koalition
gemeinsam dass wenn wir in den nächsten
haushalt gehen wir genau diesen
herausforderungen gerecht werden und das
heißt das umzusetzen was in der
koalitionsvereinbarung steht denn mit
der aufwuchs eins zu eins der mittel
vielen dank
soweit jürgen trittin hat sich auch
nochmal direkt an gregor gysi gewandt
und auf ihn folgten markus frohn mayer
fw fraktion unter anderen ist der
sprecher für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung eventuell
wird er auch auf dieses politikfeld
eingehen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin frau ministerin berbalk
wenn es nach dieser regierung geht muss
jeder deutsche in zukunft den gürtel
enger schnallen außer die regierung
selbst diese regierung verantwortet die
höchste inflation seit gründung der
bundesrepublik diese regierung stürzt
uns in eine energiekrise und diese
regierung chattet nach katar und
feministische außenpolitik zu machen sie
haben geld für jedermann außer für die
eigenen bürger
bis
2030 verschenken sie für windräder und
elektro rikschas zehn milliarden euro an
indien zehn milliarden die indien spart
milliarden für die indien russische
energie kauft sie schenken der zielinsky
regierung 4 milliarden euro unter herrn
sie lenski bewegte sich die ukraine auf
dem korruptionsindex
irgendwo zwischen dschibuti und angola
sie haben seit dem jahr 2000
afrikanischen pleitestaaten über 15
milliarden euro schulden erlassen meine
damen und herren wir all das tut während
im aartal die katastrophenopfer noch auf
unterstützung warten und familie nicht
wissen wie sie die nächste gasrechnung
bezahlen sollen der vertritt fremde
interessen und nicht die interessen der
eigenen bürger
da müssen sie gar nicht so klären das
können sie mal ernst nähmen sie nennen
das werte passiert der außenpolitik wenn
sie ein embargo fordern funktionieren
denn ihre sanktionen der russische rubel
stärker als in den letzten jahren der
handel zwischen china und russland
wächst wie sanktionieren doch in
wirklichkeit 80 millionen deutsche ihre
politik ist eine politik der wohlstands
vernichtung
und da stellt sich doch die frage was
könnte man eigentlich alles mit dem geld
positive sind deutschland bewirken
schulen krankenhäuser steuersenkungen
sie kümmern sich nicht um das wohl der
deutschen bürger die sind ihnen egal
aber die afg hat das im blick
[Applaus]
soweit markus frohn mayer fw fraktion
hatte hier nur zwei minuten redezeit
noch daher war dass er eine kurze rede
frank schabel für die spd fraktion folgt
auf ihnen er spreche für menschenrechte
und humanitäre hilfe hier in der debatte
zum etat des auswärtigen amts und
herren ich wenn dann noch mal auf den
herrn brandt antworten wollen
du und ich sehe und ich wir schätzen ja
den europarat und ich will das aber noch
mal sagen ich darf nicht zu viel detail
sagen aber dass russland
stand peter innerhalb von stunden würde
ich mal sagen rausgeschmissen wurde aus
dem europarat das war nicht so einfach
wie es nach außen ausgesehen hat und es
war notwendig dass deutschland
deutschland die führende rolle dort
eingenommen hat ich kann die länder
nicht alle aufzählen ich will sind nicht
alle aufzählen weil uns das gar nicht
hilft in der zusammenarbeit
unterstützung der ukraine aber es ist
alles andere als selbstverständlich und
wenn deutschland an manchen stellen
nicht die drängende und führende rolle
einnehmen würden dann werden wir auch
nicht so weit in der isolierung russland
ich finde das kann man zumindest auch
zur kenntnis nehmen
in diesen tagen kommen natürlich keine
debatte führen schon gar keine
außenpolitische debatte ohne zu
berücksichtigen was in der ukraine los
ist was schreckliches dieser minuten in
diesen minuten in der ukraine passiert
und es ist in der tat die zeitenwende
von der der bundeskanzler geredet hat
und es ist bitter aber es ist so dass
die friedensdividende von der wir
dachten dass wir sie hatten und wir
hatten sie haben kann man sie ja
nachlesen in den zahlen der letzten 30
jahre sie hatten wir die ist im grunde
glauben jetzt weg und sie wird gerade
entsprechend aufgefressen deswegen ist
es richtig und das eint uns in der tat
in diesem teil dieses hauses dass wir
sagen wir müssen uns militärisch stärken
nicht weil wieder lust auf haben sondern
wir müssen das entsprechend tun wir
machen das aber nicht mit großem jubel
jedenfalls in der ampelkoalition nicht
ich war ein bisschen irritiert über
manche verhaltensweisen in der union als
der kanzlerin seine rede zur zeitenwende
verhalten hat weil nämlich die
militärische antwort wichtig ist sie
geht nicht anders aber sie reicht eben
nicht aus es ist betont worden aber die
frage ist kann man das umsetzen dass man
deutlich macht wir dürfen nicht in eine
rüstungsspirale eintreten sondern müssen
andere formen von außenpolitik
entsprechend stärken in einem
umfassenden ansatz und ich glaube das
ist das was meine fraktion leisten kann
das ist das was die ampel koalition
leisten kann ich finde das ist übrigens
auch das was dieser bundeshaushalt
leistet und es ist genannt worden es ist
die humanitäre hilfe es ist die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit es ist die
krisenprävention es ist die
feministische außenpolitik es ist die
stärkung internationaler organisationen
und institutionen es ist übrigens auch
die kieler außenpolitik und es ist auch
dass vor denken ich finde auch dass man
sich muss man sich klar machen auch wenn
uns das gerade nicht vorstellen können
von neuen abrüstungsschritten es wird
das historische fenster wieder kommen
das sich öffnet oder das werden wir dann
entsprechend auch muss müssen und ich
finde dieser umfassende ansatz mit genau
in diesen bundeshaushalt
abgebildet wir sind
weltmacht geworden wirklich weltmacht
geworden in den letzten jahren in einem
bereich das ist das thema was ist der
bereich der humanitären hilfe und jürgen
trittin hat darauf hingewiesen manche
entwicklungen internationaler art haben
nochmal dazu geführt dass wir im
haushalt auch noch mal dinge verbessert
haben die am anfang nicht gut geregelt
waren weil es war so dass wir die
letzten jahre diesen aufwuchs
hinbekommen haben auf über zwei
milliarden und wir sind damit an platz
zwei weltweit und sie helfen damit nicht
nur millionen von menschen weltweit und
wir haben eben auch so diplomatische
rolle gestärkt wie wir auf
internationalen parkett haben weil wir
sehr wohl wahrgenommen werden als
zweitgrößter geber weltweit wir stärken
mit diesem haushalt eben das thema
klimadiplomatie ich habe das lange
richtig gefunden dass das thema im
auswärtigen amt verankert wird so wie es
in manchen anderen ländern schon längst
der fall war wie zum beispiel
entsprechend in großbritannien aber man
muss eben dann das amt auch mit den
entsprechenden mitteln ausstatten das
ist zumindest
gelungen manches hätte man sich mehr
gewünscht vielleicht im auswärtigen amt
aber durchaus gelungen mit diesem
haushalt und es ist wichtig dass wir
klar machen auch dort haben wir einen
umfassenden ansatz das aus werte gaben
zusammen mit dem bmz zusammen mit dem
klima innenministerium und zusammen mit
dem umweltministerien und an ministerium
und anderen arbeiten entsprechend an dem
thema und
wir stärken mit diesem haushalt die
menschenrechts architektur ein ganz
wichtiges anliegen auch des
koalitionsvertrags und zwar national und
international weil wir eben aufpassen
müssen dass im schatten der ukraine die
gefahr nicht größer wird das regime und
autokraten diese situation ausnutzen und
ihre dividende einfordern und da müssen
wir ganz vorsichtig sein das betrifft
sowohl den umgang mit china auch das ist
ja genannt worden das betrifft aber auch
den umgang mit der türkei wo scheinbar
auch die erwartung ist also jetzt nicht
die wenn dividende für wohlverhalten
entsprechend geben könnte und ich will
es noch mal unterstreichen wir haben
eher eine zuspitzung der lage in der
türkei gesehen den letzten wochen
monaten und die türkei ist schlichtweg
aufgefordert dann wird es auch keinen
kredit geben urteile umzusetzen des
europäischen gerichtshofs für
menschenrechte insbesondere muss osmann
kavala umgehend frei
aber ich will auch das sagen das
betrifft auch länder wie zum beispiel
indien eine demokratie aber auch mit
schwierigen tendenzen im bereich des
hindu nationalismus
auch da werden wir uns kritisch mit
auseinandersetzen müssen und auch da
müssen wir deutlich machen auch da kann
es kein kredit geben für wohlverhalten
möglicherweise eben auf internationaler
ebene
wir stärken die menschenrechts
eigentlich tektur in deutschland wir
stärken das deutsche institut für
menschenrechte nicht in diesem haushalt
hier aber insgesamt im haushalt wir
stärken die osze wir stärken den
internationalen strafgerichtshof den
hohen menschenrechtskommissar stärken
aber auch den europarat mit
elf millionen euro relativ wenig geld im
vergleich zu diesem großen haus hat aber
eine riesengroße bedeutung die
ministerin konnte glänzen habe ich
gehört in turin
treffen der ministerinnen und minister
und ich will das noch mal sagen es ist
eine riesenchance auch diesen europarat
zu nutzen in einer situation wo uns
allen klar ist dass wir südosteuropa den
westbalkan stärker an europa heranführen
müssen und manches über die europäische
union nicht sofort gehen wird dann ist
es eine gute möglichkeit am ende diesen
europarat zu nutzen indem zum beispiel
kosovo so schnell wie es geht mitglied
auch dieses europarats wird vielen
herzlichen dank
frank schwabe waren es für die spd
fraktion
und in gleicher funktion allerdings wie
die fdp ist peter heidt auch er spreche
für menschenrechte und humanitäre hilfe
seiner fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegen gelegen in mehreren 1 plänen
des bundeshaushaltes gibt es
menschenrechts basierte titel dies
entspricht unserem koalitionsvertrag
verankerten grundsatz dass
menschenrechtspolitik alle aspekte des
staatlichen handelns auf internationaler
wie auch in politischer ebene umfasst
gleichzeitig spiegelt dies das wachsen
ausmaß und das zunehmende komplexität
von krisen und konflikten weltweit
wieder letztendlich ist es aber auch ein
beweis dafür dass die bundesregierung
ihrer verpflichtung ernst nimmt dass
menschenrechte trotz wachsender
herausforderung dezidiert zu verteidigen
sind und sich dass sich dabei eine
differenzierte herangehensweise
entschieden hat nicht erst seit dem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff in der
ukraine steigt der bedarf an humanitärer
hilfe weltweit die mittel die wir jetzt
zur verfügung stellen um diesen bedarf
zu decken wachsen deutschland ist jetzt
der zweitgrößte geldgeber an humanitärer
hilfe weltweit und im rüdiger brandt wir
reden nicht nur wir handeln tatsächlich
dass der unterschied zu der alten
bundesregierung
und dies liegt gerade auch im interesse
deutschlands
denn zum einen gewinnen wie durch die
hilfe partner auf der welt für unsere
werte und natürlich verhindern wir damit
auch eine flüchtlingskatastrophe die
nicht in unserem interesse liegt wir
geben den menschen die chance in ihren
heimatländern zu bleiben das ist auch
sehr wichtig in vielen ländern gerät die
zivilgesellschaft immer mehr unter druck
und zivile handlungsspielräume werden
massiv eingeschränkt ist andere
journalisten aktivist wissenschaftler
anderer menschenrechtsverteidiger
riskieren durch ihre arbeit selbst zum
opfer von menschenrechtsverletzungen zu
werden gerade sie sind dabei
unverzichtbar für den aufbau und erhalt
eines funktionierenden gemeinwesens
diesen mut die menschen müssen wir
unterstützen und deshalb freue ich mich
sehr dass wir die mittel für die
digitalisierung von visa verfahren zur
verfügung stellen damit die
antragstellung für diejenigen bedrohten
menschen erleichtert werden die keine
möglichkeit haben eine botschaft zu
erreichen
und ebenso freue ich mich darüber dass
wir unserem versprechen wahrmachen
förder und schutzprogramme für bedrohte
menschenrechtsverteidiger auszubauen
unter anderem die elisabeth selbert
initiative wird gestärkt gerade weil wir
auf die zusammenarbeit und die expertise
von internationalen und nationalen
organisationen angewiesen sind kommen
wir unserem versprechen diese kassen
länder finanziell besser auszustatten
auch nach beispielsweise ist hier das
deutsche institut für menschenrechte zu
nennen sechs zusätzliche stellen oder
letzter punkt ist mir wichtig kein
frieden ohne gerechtigkeit dazu gehört
auch dass gerade kriegsverbrechen
aufgeklärt und die verantwortlichen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden das gilt für
die ukraine wo immer mehr
kriegsverbrecher ans tageslicht kommen
das gilt aber auch für alle anderen
konfliktregionen
dieser verbrechen müssen dokumentiert
werden und wir müssen die im
koalitionsvertrag angekündigten ausbau
der kapazitäten für verfahren im bereich
des völkerstrafrechts ganz da
vorantreiben liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir befinden uns in einem
system wettbewerb demokratie gegen
diktatur
wir brauchen den engen austausch und den
zusammenhalt in europäischen und
transnationalen atlantischen partnern
gleichzeitig müssen wir ihnen ein
zuverlässiger partner sein und wenn uns
das gelingt dann können wir aus dieser
stärke heraus auch unsere werte durch
die vielen dank
als nächstes erhält das wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion der kollege thomas r
[Applaus]
vielen dank sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren
herr kollege hat die handlungsfähigkeit
und diese tolle leistung der regierung
das ist unterm strich wenig glaubwürdig
wenn das hier beschworen wird wenn aus
den eigenen reihen letztendlich genügend
damen und herren da sind in die gleiche
kerbe schlagen wie wir das als union
machen da
haben sie kein geschlossenes bild das
letztendlich auch die glaubwürdigkeit
dann unterminiert meine damen und herren
vor wenigen tagen habe ich die holocaust
gedenkstätte jad vaschem in jerusalem
besucht ein zutiefst
bedrückender ort und besonders schmerzt
der gang durch die gedenkstätte für die
1,5 millionen ermordeten kind eine
dunkle höhle ein raum der nicht greifbar
ist und in dem sich fünf kerzen so oft
spiegeln dass man glaubt unter einem
sternenhimmel zu sein im hintergrund
werden die namen der ermordeten kinder
vorgelesen mira goldmann sechs jahre alt
ermordet in der ukraine
rubin weinstein zwei jahre alt der morde
in der ukraine oder riva grossmann 3
jahre alt ermordeten versorgung im jahr
1941 es dauert drei monate bis alle
namen vorgelesen wurden meine damen und
herren in der ukraine auch in saison
wird wieder gemordet 81 jahre nach dem
privatteam und mehr durch die nazis und
ihre handlanger umgebracht wurden
sterben dort wieder heraus haben kinder
und da möchte ich die frage an die
bundesregierung und die ampel fraktionen
richten was bedeutet eigentlich nie
wieder was bedeutet das eigentlich
angesichts des russischen
vernichtungskrieges mitten in europa was
bedeutet denn nie wieder wenn wir einen
schon wieder vor unserer haustür haben
einen angriffskrieg basierend auf
rassismus und großmacht fantasien wir
sind immer gut darin wenn es um das
erinnern geht erinnern an die verbrechen
der vergangenheit das ist wichtig aber
erinnern darf nicht bloß ein ritual sein
sondern aus dem erinnern müssen konkrete
schlüsse für das hier und jetzt gezogen
werden da muss konkretes handeln auch
folgen und da muss ich sagen das ist
einfach nicht ausreichend was die
bundesregierung hier macht nie wieder
muss doch bedeuten dass wir entschieden
und entschlossen handeln aus einer
position der stärke agieren und nicht
eben durch zaudern und ängstlichkeit für
irritationen bei unseren freunden und
partnern sorgen
frau bundesministerin sie haben vor
einigen wochen zum thema
waffenlieferungen gesagt es darf jetzt
keine ausreden mehr geben wieso suchen
dann teile der regierung jede woche eine
neue ausrede wenn es um die lieferung
schwerer waffen geht setzen sie sich nur
sie haben dabei unsere unterstützung
meine kolleginnen und kollegen das bild
deutschlands vor allem in osteuropa ist
verheerend und das ist nicht mein urteil
sondern es ist durch viele aussagen
belegt zuletzt auch durch den polnischen
präsidenten und ist das nun die lehren
aus unserer geschichte dass viele länder
glauben wenn es darauf ankommt dann kann
man sich auch deutschland nicht
verlassen kann es unser ziel sein dass
der ukrainische außenminister sagt er
habe es satt auch deutschland zu warten
vor der bundesministerin sie haben an
dieser stelle bei der ersten lesung des
haushalts selber gesagt ihnen geht das
auch an die nieren nie wieder muss doch
heißen dass wir den sinnlosen sterben
von reverse rubins und mehr aus
ukrainischen nachfahren ein ende setzen
und das geht eben nur wenn die ukraine
richtig bewegt ist sich zur wehr zu
setzen das geht nur wenn wir auch auf
dem wenn wir auch zu dem punkt kommen
das umfassend neues gerät eingesetzt
wird und dann muss man auch ein paar
monate in die zukunft denken und da muss
auch die anzahl der fahrzeuge und
systeme angemessen sein und nicht nur
die symbolik mit wenigen stück es geht
nämlich nicht darum irgendetwas zu
liefern irgendwie auch bei den
unterstützern dabei zu sein und diesen
eindruck hat man leider von dieser
bundesregierung und dieser eindruck geht
auch durch diese
selbstgefälligkeit in der der kanzler
heute morgen wieder einmal die angeblich
so große unterstützung gepriesen hat
eben auch nicht weg denn es geht doch
darum ein ziel zu erreichen ein ziel das
auch sie formuliert haben russland darf
nicht gewinnen die ukraine muss gewinnen
und an diesem ziel muss unser handeln
ausgerichtet sein und da müssen wir
deutlich pragmatischer werden die
ukraine investieren zeit und personal
für die bedienung der panzerhaubitze
2000 und wir wir liefern sieben stück
wir haben 60 stück nicht einsatzbereit
ist es für die viertgrößte
wirtschaftsmacht der welt ein problem
diese blitze den wenigen monaten
einsatzbereit zu machen dann könnten wir
deutlich mehr als den bestand liefern
und damit hätten wir schon vor drei
monaten anfangen sollen und genau so
versteht niemand aroma und leo ein tag
der industrie nicht schon längst im
einsatz sind
meine damen und herren
politischen sonntagsreden kommt oft
europa muss souveräner werden auch in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag findet sich so
eine aussage
europa kann aber nur souveräner werden
wenn mitgliedsländer vorangehen und
deutschland hat ja eine führungsrolle
aber es ist keine führung wenn wir immer
nur unter druck handeln heute wurde
verkündet wir liefern jetzt mehrfach
raketenwerfer gute entscheidung aber
nicht aus eigenem antrieb sondern weil
der us-präsident angerufen hat das ist
doch keine führung das ist deutlich mehr
souveränität das ist eine verzerrung der
eu wollen wir so weiter machen meine
damen und herren
und das geht weiter diese regierung hat
keine meinung beim ju kandidatenstatus
dabei verteidigen die tapferen
kämpferinnen und kämpfer unsere werte
unsere sicherheit unserer europa frei
und demokratisch und ich möchte dass wir
eine rückendeckung und vertrauen und ein
klares signal für den weg in die eu
geben
das ist alles beschämend und traurig und
ich habe noch nie von so vielen menschen
den satz gehört ich schäme mich für mein
land und das ist die verantwortung des
bundeskanzlers und deswegen frau
ministerin sorgen sie bitte dafür dass
deutschland in dieser krise beherzt
handeln dass wir ein verlässlicher
partner für unsere freunde gerade in
osteuropa sind und das sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr ist dabei ein
wichtiges signal
es ist gut dass sie und ihre partei
jetzt bereit sind diese
107 letzter satz frau präsidentin gehen
sie bitte auch bei den lieferungen
schwerer waffen für die ukraine genauso
voran und dann haben sie uns an ihrer
seite herzlichen dank
thomas engel war dass damit kommen wir
zum letzten redner in dieser debatte
allerdings dürfte es thematisch dabei
auch um ähnliche aspekte gehen danach
wird der etat des
verteidigungsministeriums
besprochen und auch die
bundesverteidigungsminister rinn
christine lambrecht ist er auch schon
die ganze zeit seit der debatte dabei
nicht wiederholen aber wir haben uns
gerade nochmal den beleg wohl lassen
also gehen sie sich bitte nicht so an
sondern immer sachlich versuchen sie es
bitte auf sachliche art und weise vielen
dank jetzt erhält das wort johannes
schraps für die inter hier gab es noch
eine ermahnung an gunther krichbaum für
kommentare beziehungsweise zwischenrufe
dass die sachlicher sein sollen verehrte
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen lieber kollege
ernte wenn sie sich das schämen dann
kann ich das sie so reden nachvollziehen
weil sie ganz offensichtlich dann mit so
vielen menschen in ihrem wahlkreis
sprechen die alle ganz anders denken als
bei ganz vielen anderen kolleginnen und
kollegen das hat jedenfalls die debatte
aus meiner sicht sehr deutlich gezeigt
eines ist aus dieser debatte aber glaube
ich auch wenn ich das als letzter redner
so sagen darf sehr deutlich
hervorgegangen dass die gräueltaten
russlands in der ukraine uns tagtäglich
vor augen führen dass die ukraine nie
wieder das land werden wird was sie vor
diesem krieg war und dasselbe gilt für
uns in deutschland und für den
europäischen kontinent auch denn mit dem
russischen angriffskrieg ist nichts mehr
wie früher und dass sich diese
zeitenwende natürlich auch in unseren
haushalten widerspiegelt ich glaube das
ist völlig normal europa als friedens
kontinent wie wir es über jahrzehnte als
vollkommen selbstverständlich
hinnehmen durften diese realität die hat
putin mit seinem angriffskrieg brutal
zerstört und ich möchte deshalb zum
abschluss dieser debatte die worte die
auch der bundeskanzler heute morgen
erneut benutzt hat unbedingt noch mal
wiederholen putin darf und wird diesen
krieg nicht gewinnen verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen denn nur so
kann europa irgendwann wieder zum
friedens kontinent werden
und der kriege in der ukraine dieser
krieg auf europäischem boden der prägt
eben natürlich alle bereiche auch
unseres lebens und deshalb ist es nur
logisch dass er auch auswirkungen auf
unsere finanz- und haushaltsplanung hat
putins krieg gegen die ukraine braucht
geschlossene antworten der eu oder
braucht eben auch antworten aus
deutschland und weil es uns um die
zukunft europas und um unsere
verantwortung gegenüber der ukraine geht
geben wir mit diesen vorgelegten
haushalt auch antworten verehrte
kolleginnen polen
und natürlich ist dieser haushalt leben
geprägt von den eindrücken des krieges
und der haushalt den uns die
berichterstatterin und berichterstatter
den ich an dieser stelle zum abschluss
auch noch mal ganz herzlich danken
möchte vorgelegt haben der ist aus
meiner sicht sehr gut austariert und
wohlüberlegt und ich freue mich dass vor
allem für den bereich der humanitären
hilfe und für die unterstützung der
ukraine als angegriffen im land viele
viele mittel in diesem haushalt
eingeplant wurden und mit denen 2,7
milliarden euro
die richtigerweise im bereich der
humanitären hilfe liegen kollege gysi da
kann man doch wenn ein drittel dieses
haushalts des auswärtigen amtes für
humanitäre hilfe aufgewandt wird nicht
von einem militaristischen haushalt in
diesem bereich sprechen das dann können
sie entweder den haushalt nicht gelesen
haben oder sie wussten schon vor
aufstellung des haushalts was sie hier
am pult zu dieser debatte sagen sollen
wir kommen schlichtweg unserer
verantwortung nach die wir gegenüber der
ukraine haben das haben außenministerin
berbalk auch michelle müntefering und
andere rednerinnen und redner gesagt
denn durch diese hilfe im humanitären
bereich wird die hilfe mit unterstützung
zahlreicher partner organisationen dort
geleistet wo sie am allernötigsten ist
nämlich für die menschen in der ukraine
wo es aufgrund der russischen angriffe
und des riesigen der riesigen
zerstörungen in der infrastruktur des
landes häufig am lebensnotwendigsten
fehlt und da müssen wir helfen verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen diesem haushalt
stellen wir die mittel dafür zur
verfügung
und außerdem unterstützen wir die
zivilbevölkerung in der ukraine aber
auch dass es angesprochen worden in
russland in belarus und in anderen
ländern osteuropas wo das dringend
notwendig ist dazu zählen
journalistinnen und journalisten
studierende wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftler oppositionelle die
derzeit nicht oder nur unter ganz großer
gefahr oder gefahr für ihr leben ihrer
arbeit nachgehen können und durch die
aufstockung der mittel im zuge der
haushaltsberatungen fördern wir zudem
auch mehrere projekte die sich für den
erhalt von meinungsvielfalt und gegen
falschmeldungen einsetzen das ist
wichtig weil leider nicht mehr überall
die freiheitsrechte gelten die wir in
unserem demokratischen system hier
gewohnt sind verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen mit
bedacht haben wir auch das hat kollege
hat richtig gesagt
maßnahmen wie die finanzierung von
ermittlungsverfahren gegen
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine und auch
die unterstützung von besonders grüne
radlerin partnerländern wie
beispielsweise der moldau die selten
genannt wird ja aber als kleines land
mit nicht einmal drei millionen
einwohnerinnen und einwohnern besonders
viele schutz suchende menschen aus der
ukraine aufgenommen hat und ebenfalls
große unterstützung von uns nötig hat
und diese auch bekommen feierte
kolleginnen und kollegen und ich halte
es für ausgesprochen wichtig dass wir
gerade vor dem hintergrund der
auswirkungen des krieges auch die
beziehungen zu unseren europäischen
partnerländern weiter stärken und
intensivieren und auch das tun wir mit
dem vorliegenden haushalt und da will
ich nur einige wenige exemplarische
beispiele nennen ich freue mich zum
beispiel sehr dass der ansatz für die
stiftung deutsch polnische
zusammenarbeit deutlich erhöht wird und
auch die 2020 ins leben gerufene
elisabeth selbert initiative des iva des
instituts für auslandsbeziehungen die
geflüchtete
menschenrechtsverteidigerinnen und
menschenrechtsverteidiger unterstützt
wird noch einmal besser ausgestattet das
sind alles wichtige projekte die uns
auch in der zusammenarbeit mit unseren
europäischen partnern helfen
gestärkt werden die beziehung zu unseren
europäischen partnern aber vor allem
auch durch gegenseitiges kennenlernen
und durch das abbauen von vorbehalten
deshalb halte ich es für ausgesprochen
richtig dass wir auch im wichtigen fokus
legen auf die austauschprogramme
insbesondere auf jugendaustausch mit der
erhöhung der mittel für die
internationale jugendbegegnungsstätte im
polnischen kreisau mit der stärkung der
des netzwerks der bereits genannten pass
schulen oder mit der stärkung der
jugendarbeit des europarates all das
wichtige maßnahmen die zu europäischem
zusammenhalt beitragen verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen zum abschluss
gerade in den heutigen zeiten da würde
uns ganz klar dass europa nur
miteinander solidarisch sein kann und
muss das ist der einzige weg für uns um
stabil und widerstandsfähig zu bleiben
und um als europäer zusammen zu stehen
und mit einer stimme zu sprechen diese
prioritäten spiegelt dieser
haushaltsplan eindrucksvoll wider wir
stellen uns den herausforderungen die
uns diese bewegten zeiten auferlegen als
ampelkoalition tragen wir mit diesem
haushalt unseren teil zu europäischen
antwort auf den angriffskrieg putins bei
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank ich schließe die debatte wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan 05 auswärtiges amt in der
ausschuss fassung wer stimmt für den
einzelplan 05 in der ausschuss fassung
das ist die spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp wer stimmt dagegen dass es cdu
csu fdp und die linke enthaltung
entsprechend keine der einzelplan 05 ist
angenommen